الجمهوري بايدن لن يخسر الانتخابات اذا
كان المرشحه
الامريكان اشتغلوا على موضوع
الشواذ على موضوع تطبيعه مع المتحولين
ويقول لك يا اخي هذا رجالي الحمام الحريم
اه هنا لا وقف ما عاد صاروا
[موسيقى]
الدين علاقه الدوله بالدين ما هو اليمين
واليسار في الثقافه الامريكيه وهل تغير من
البدايات الى الان
الاحزاب تغيراتها فكيف تغير الجمهوريين من
حزب ليبرالي يقود حربا على العبوديه الى
حزب محافظ وكيف تغير الديمقراطي من العكس
الى العكس اسئله كثيره لفهم الداخل
الامريكي مع افضل من يشرحه ويبسط ضيفي
احمد الحنطي سبق واصبرت في حلقه سابقه هي
متممه لهذه الحلقه عن اساسيات السياسه
الامريكيه
قبل ان نبدا
بكل حلقه من فنجان في كواليس نقاشات
تسولات كثيره
بدءا من سبب اختيارنا للمواضيع او الضيوف
والتحديات والنقاشات اللي تصير خلف كل
حلقه هذه كلها معلومات احيانا مشاركتها
تكون رائعه لكن ما كان في قالب نقدر نضع
في
نشر هذه المعلومات فبتكون فيه نشره بريديه
كل احد مع موعد نشر الحلقه الصوتيه
اشترك في النشره من خلال الرابط الموجود
فيه وصف الحلقه وشارك مع من تعتقد انها
تهمه اما الان
لنبدا
بالطياره ما اقعد بالكرسي الاول ابد قالوا
ليش صارت طاوله بالكرز جنب
الوالد يقول طيب اطول رجل قلت
[ضحك]
رحلاتكم طويله
حنا نطلع من هيوستن بدبي 16 ساعه
واذا مني يعني صرت عجل جيت على الافتانزن
عشر ساعات ونص بعدين
الله يعينك
يعني من الرياض للرياض والله
انه
خبز البخيل الماكولا
احلى مدينه في الدنيا للمعيشه
[ضحك]
في الحلقه الاولى
اسكان
ترى حتى قبلها
يعني خلاص
[ضحك]
يعني
تقدر تعرف
تغير تقدر تقراه ولا ما تغيرت
يعني التغير موجود
ولكنه ترى يعني في المجتمع
تغير على السطح بس لكن تحت تغير
بروح الحين رايح امريكا
يمكنك يا اخي امريكا يعني مثلا
في ريحه امريكا ما عادت صارت امريكي
ترى ممكن تموت فيه باي ماسك اي قتل كذا
عام فهل هي بس الصوره العامه في الاعلام
ولا الحقيقه الناس خايفه شوف المس زادت
زادت في يعني يمكن في العشر سنوات الاخيره
ولكن ايضا تركيز اعلام عليها زاد اضعاف
مضاعفه لانه الاعلام يرى انه ارتكب خطا
بعدم التركيز على موضوع
لانه هذا اعطى الناس يعني قلل من حجم
المشكله في عيون الناس
مثلا لو انا في امريكا يمكن جيت مثلا نقول
ترى في حرب ترى مدري ايش زي كذا ما في ولا
شيء بس الاعلام
فما ادري اذا امريكا فعلا الاعلان يعني
انت عارف امريكا قاره
عدد الحوادث اللي فيها ما هو كبير بس انه
اي شيء اكثر من صفر يعتبر كثير في النهايه
بس هو فعلا يعني ازدياد في الارقام
الازدياد اقل بكثير من الازدياد في
التغطيه يعني اذا التغطيه زاد اذا الحوادث
زادت مثلا عشرين ثلاثين في المئه التغطيه
زادت 3000%
في تضخيم في التغذيه وتضخيم مقصود ما هو
يعني من الطرفين من كل الاطراف
ميديا
تحاول دائما انها تكون محايده قدر
المستطاع ولكن لانه بطبيعه النيده دائما
يشتغلون فيها عاده مثقفين والمثقفين عادهم
الديمقراطيين اكثر لكنهم في عملهم يحاولون
يكونون محايدين ويحاولون يغطون هذه من
وجهه نظر محايده ولكنه اهم شيء انه انه
لازم نقنع الناس انه هذه مشكله كبيره
تحتاجها
ممكن يعتبرون ترى من ستريم ممكن ما
يعتبرون ولكنه غالبا اللي يعتبر اللي نشرت
الاخبار حقت
اللي هي القناه ما هو الفوكس
اضافه المحليه اضافه الى القنوات الرادو
والتلفزيون المحليه
وفيهم اليمين و اليسار
فكلهم الاثنين الحين متفقين على الاسلحه
فيها اشكال عشان
بس كيف نحله مختلفين
يعني طبيعه طبيعه السياسه لما يكون عندك
في تعدديه وهذا كويس ترى لانه لما يكون
عندك تيار واحده مسيطر تبدا تتطرف تتطرف
تتطرف لانه دائما كل ما يزايد احد يجي من
يزايد اكثر منه ويجي من يزايد اكثر من
وهكذا لما يكون عندك لا طرفين كل واحد
يوازن الثاني
تكون دائما الارضيه المشتركه الكويس من
هذا مع كويس من هذا ونشيل الشطحات حقت هذا
ونشيل الشطحات ويصير العمليه متوازنه
ولكنه المشكله في الولايات اللي ما فيها
توازن يعني لما تيجي الولايه مثلا يعني
عندنا
بعد الجريمه البشع اللي صارت قاعدين
يتكلمون على تركيب بوابات على المدارس
وعلى ليش الشرطي ما كان موجود
الجزئيه التافه وتاركين المشكله الرئيسيه
انه واحد عنده مشكله وحاول يشتري سلاح
ورفض واول ما كان مثلا 18 سنه راحوا
اشتروا سلاح وراحوا عشرين بزر يعني
بكل بساطه يعني
الجزئيه الثانيه لانهم
يتقاربون
انها صارت يمين يمين ويسار يسار فصار
استقطاب حاد جدا وصارنا نشوف هذه
التباينات
كل واحد يزايد عشان يبعد اكثر فعلا يعني
الاستقطاب ارتفع كثير في السنوات الاخيره
والمشكله يعني لو تلاحظ الولايات الكبيره
هي اللي فيها اعلى استقطاب وهذه المشكله
الكبيره كميه كبيره الولايات الكبيره يعني
يمكن عندك اكبر الولايات طبعا اللي اربع
ولايات اللي هي كاليفورنيا نيويورك
هذه اكبر اربع ولايات يجي بعدها مجموعه
ولايه ايضا تعتبر ولايه كبيره بعدين نبدا
ندخل في الولايات الصغيره يعني انت لما
تتكلم على الولايه زي كاليف سكانها خمسه
مليون امريكا كلها 350 مليون فيعني
كاليفورنيا ثقل كبير من ناحيه عدد السكان
من ناحيه الاقتصاد يعني كاليفورنيا وتكساس
تنافس الدول كحجم اقتصاد ما تنافس
الولايات الثانيه يعني الولايات ما يمكن
انك تفكر مجرد تفكير انك تقارنه زي مثلا
متسبه
ولايه الاقتصاد يعني نتكلم عن الناتج محلي
بالتريليونات
في هذه الولايات هي مركز الاستقطاب العالي
لانه مع الكثافه السكانيه يزيد سيطره
نوعيه معينه من السكان
سيطره حزب معين ويبدا الشطح يعني لو تلاحظ
اغنى ولايتين في امريكا هم اللي يعانونوا
من مشاكل في الكهرباء
اللي راحوا يسار على مشاكل الكهرباء
طبعا الاسباب مختلفه ولكن النتيجه واحده
في كاليفورنيا صاروا يبغون يتوجهون نحو
طاقه نظيفه بسرعه فسووا الضغط على عمليه
التوليد فسببت لهم مشاكل نقص في التوليد
في تكساس
المحافظه الاقتصاديه تقول خلي السوق مفتوح
مئه في الميه وما حد يتدخلها في اي شيء
واتركه السوق مفتوح السوق ما كان مرن
لضمان كميه كهربا تكفي ستنقطع الكهرباء
عاصفه يعني غير نادر تجي زي كذا ولكنه لما
يكون سياسه دوله سياسه الدوله تضع
احتياطات اكبر لما يكون عندك انت عندك
مثلا تحتاج 100 سرير في العنايه المركزه
الدوله تقول لها القطاع الخاصه
بسبت المشكله يوم جيت تجمدت
المولدات واضطروا يفصلون الكهرباء عن
الغالبيه تكساس عشان ما يطفونها على
المستشفيات
طيب عشان نفهم كل هذه يعني امريكا من
الدول اللي صعب فهمنا
فعشان نفهم وتاثيرها عالي فحس فهمها مهم
نرجع شوي الى بداياتها فبدايات امريكا
يعني عشان نفهم من هو المستوى الامريكي
بدايتهم اوروبيين كانوا يعيشون تحت سلطه
السلطه الدينيه
وهاجر وهرب منها الى امريكا بالضبط بالضبط
الى حد كبير الكلام هذا صحيح
الاستعمار امريكا يعني مستوطنات في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تركها متاخر
هذا الشيء
يعني احنا نتكلم عن كولومبوس اول مره وصل
لامريكا كان
1492 و93 اول مستعمره انشات في الولايات
المتحده سنه 1607 يعني انا اتكلم على انه
ما بدا اصلا انشاء المستعمرات الا في
القرن السابع عشر
وبدايه المستعمرات كانوا فعلا كانوا
انجليز
هاربين من اضطهاد الديني في بريطانيا لانه
في بريطانيا صارت عندهم عمليه تغيير
الكنيسه من الكنيسه
الثامن وقصته لما طلعت الكنيسه في ناس
ارفضوا انهم يتحولون الكنيسه الجديده بقوا
على ديانه الكاثوليكيه وفي ناس وهذول هم
اللي كانوا المهاجرين الاوائل اللي جو
الامريكي لا اقلبها ولكنه كانوا يقولون
الاصلاح اللي تم للكنيسه الانجليزيه بموقف
لا في اشياء ما سووها في اشياء ما زالوا
فيها الكنيسه الكاثوليكيه لازم تتغير
فكانوا مضطهدين بسبب افكارهم الدينيه هذه
فهاجروا روحوا الهولندا على اساس انه
هولندا اسبح دينيا بعدين من هولندا راحوا
لامريكا هذه كانت اول مستعمرات هذولي
نفسهم بعدين في امريكا
على بعضهم
في قصص مشهوره في تاريخ امريكا على ناس
يعني تم تم فيهم برا المستعمر اطلع في
البر بس لا تعيش معنا
ويعتبرون يعني الشخصيات تاريخيه فرغم انهم
هم اصلا كانوا هاربين لانهم
في اللي يسمونهم الابن الثاني الحين في
الاسر الاستقراطيه كان الابن البكر اكبر
الاولاد واللي يعرف كل شيء
على اساس انه الثوره ثروه الاسره تبقى
مركزه في مكان واحد بحيث انها تبقى قوته
وسلطته متوارثه على اجيال اذا كان عنده
لقب كل المزارع كل الاملاك كل الفلوس كل
شيء يرثون قبل الاكبر الابن الثاني اصلا
هنا لانه ابن لاسره ارستقراطيه لا تعلم
مهنه لا تعلم شيء ومع دور ولا عنده ابلاك
ولا عنده شيء فما المستقبل
كثير انه كان يروح الكنيسه يصيرون يعني
رجال الكنيسه
فهذول الناس انا ابي ابني اسمي وثروتي في
العالم الجديد
الفئه الثالثه كانوا الفئه الناس
شغل اصلا فقالت
فاول ما جاء لامريكا كانت العمليه صعبه
جدا وكادت تفشل يعني كان عمليه انشاء
المستعمرات لانه غير مؤهلين يعني الناس
اللي جوا كلهم غير مؤهلين انهم يبنون
اقتصاد جديد ودوله جديده
انقذهم طبعا زراعه الدخان لانه دخان اكتشف
في امريكا اصلا ما كان معروف قبل امريكا
فكانوا في مستعمره جيمس تاون كانت يعني
اكبر مستعمره بدات في امريكا في البدايه
قدروا يوصلون يعني البذره معينه معينه
قابله للتصدير وممكن يمشي سوقها تنافس
التبغه اللي كان يروح من اماكن ثانيه تحت
فتره اسبانيا
فانتعشوا وبدوا يعيشون على تصدير التبغ
وذره البطاطس هذه كلها اشياء جايه من
امريكا ما كانت معروفه قبل امريكا
بعد كذا بدات توسع بداوا يجيبون ناس بعقود
عمل يعني عبيد عقود عمل ولكن عقود سخره
ناس ميتين من الجوع في اوروبا تعال انا
بدفع لك مصاريفك تروح لامريكا ولكنك تسدد
لي مصاريف هذه مراتبك المشكله ان طول ما
هو في امريكا ويتراكم عليه ديون اصلا
فيقعد طول يعني فترات غالبيه حياته وهو
يعيش تحت نظام سخره بعدين جوا العبيد من
افريقيا العميد طبعا بعضهم كان يشتروا
بعضهم كانوا يخطف وبداوا يجيبونهم خصوصا
مع توسع زراعه القطن
بعدين عاد بدات تكونت اللي هي المستعمرات
13 بعدين اعلنوا استقلالهم بعدين بداوا
يتوسعون اكثر طبعا وقتها كانوا الفرنسيين
والاسبان كلهم موجودين غير البريطانيين
موجودين كانت تبع فرنسا
فلوريدا اسبانيا طبعا جنوب امريكا
الولايات اللي جنوب امريكا الان هذا
الحزام كله من كاليفورنيا الى فلوريدا
كان ضمن حدود المكسيك واخذ بطرق مختلفه
شيب حرب وشيب شراء وشيب وسلم
كانوا في حرب
واتفقوا على شرائها قبل لا يعني هم فازوا
في الحرب قبل لا يوصل الخبر لاوروبا بينما
كانوا مناديبهم في اوروبا قاعدين يدفعون
قيمتها
بعد التوسع يوم جاء الاستقلال
جاهم فكره الاضطهاد الديني انه حنا اصلا
كثير منا كان هارب من هذا الديني ومع ذلك
مارسناه
كتبت الدستور كانوا مفكرين يعني كانوا
مثقفين
فكان عندهم هذا موجود من قبل وكان موجود
في كتاباته من قبل فحرصوا على انه ينحط في
الدستور انه الدوله ما لها علاقه بالكنيسه
الكنيسه اللي هي المؤسسه الدينيه وليس
الدين انه المؤسس الدينيه هذه لا تتدخل في
الدوله نهائيا والدوله تقف على مسافه
واحده من كل المذاهب وقتها كانوا كلهم
مسيحيين فما كانوا يفكرون في المذاهب
المسيحيه بس كانوا يكفرون بعض ما يعتبرون
بعض من نفس الدين يعني كان في كان فيهم
بعضهم متطرفين جدا يعني جدا جدا يعني يعني
اعطني مثالك يعني الحين ما تحضرني في ذهني
ولكنه كانوا يخرجون الواحد من المله
لخلافات جزئيه يعني انت تقول مثلا قد لا
يكون دقيق انه اذا الواحد اذا مات هل ممكن
يتعذب اول بعدين يروح الجنه ولا اذا دخل
النار ما يروح الجنه خلاص على الجزئيه هذه
انا كفرك واطلعكم برا البلد يعني كانوا
جدا جدا صار عندهم درجات عاليه انه تطرف
ومن فعشان كذا كان عندهم الهجسس هذا قوي
وكانوا حريصين على تاسيسهم من البدايه ما
عنده مشكله انتم متدين كيفك انت بتسوي
كنيسه انت بتصلي انت حتى بتصوت بناء على
ايمانك الديني وقناتك الدينيه ما عندك
مشكله بس ما تيجي تقول انا لازم اصوت بناء
على قناتك كنت لا
ما تيجي تقول لي هذا القانون لازم يمر
لانه حرام ولا لانه حلال لا هذا ما هو حجه
انت تصوت للقانون لانك ترى انه حرام ولا
حلال حر بس ما تيجي تحجون عليك انت ما هي
علي انا كل الاباء المؤسسين كانوا متفقين
على هذه الفكره
موضوع الفصل ما كان ما هو من الاشياء اللي
دار عليها نقاش اصلا والمجتمع الامريكي
انا ذاك قابل لهذه الفكره المجتمع يعني ما
في دراسات واضحه اطلعت عليها انا قد يكون
فيها شيء ما طلعت عليها ما في دراسات
واضحه كانت تناقش هل الشعب كان متقبل ولا
لا لانه الشعب اصلا لما صارت الحرب في جزء
من الشعب الامريكي اصلا راح مع الانجليز
كان ضد الاستقلال كانوا يرون انه لا حنا
تبع الملك ولازم واجب علينا طاعه الملك
فكانت هي عباره عن يعني هي تصنف حرب
استقلال ولكن الى حد ما كانت
انقسموا قسمين اضافه الى الانجليز بعد ما
انتصروا الدستور الجديد خلاص يعني لم
يناقش
في افكار كثيره مثلا يعني مثل موضوع
العبوديه مثل موضوع سلطات الحكومه
الفيدراليه مثل موضوع الاحزاب هذه كلها
كانت مواضيع شده بس الموضوع الفصل
لما تقول انه فصل الدين على الدوله كان
شكل من اشكال تشكيل الدستور
واتفاق ما بينهم هل هذا يعطي دلاله انه
كان في ضعف ديني في المجتمع الامريكي
فقط لانه الامريكان تاريخيا وحتى اليوم هم
اكثر اكثر المجتمعات الغربيه لدينا
يعني هم يعتبرون متدينين ومحافظين يعني
تقليديين اكثر من اي مجتمع غربي ثاني
لا من ناحيه نسب زياره الكنيسه لا من
ناحيه يعني التعريف انه يعرف نفسه هل انا
اعرف نفسي اني منتمي لديانه معينه ولا لا
غير منتمي وخلاص
لانه في كثير من المسيحيين الان صار يعني
يعرف نفسهم غير منتنم ما يصنف نفسه مسيحي
بس انه من اسره مسيحيه
ويمارس الطقوس المسيحيه كنوع من العادات
الاجتماعيه وليس كالنوع من الدين بينما في
امريكا
نسبهم بالمسيحيين
الاعلى في العالم الغربي كله يعني وبفارق
ملموس يعني
نتكلم على ارقام اكبر من كذا لان هذا يعني
عجيب كيف انه اليوم هي برضو مو بس حتى على
هذا على القوانين على تلقى انه امريكا
اكثر محافظه من اوروبا
بفارق كبير فعلا بسبب طبيعه الشعب بسبب
الطبيعه المحافظه للشعب رغم انهم طلعوا من
التهاديني فكانت اوروبا اكثر تدينا اي في
فرق ما بين يعني شوف في فرق ما بين التدين
وما بين الاضطهاد يعني ترى
الفكره انهم هم عندهم التقبل للجديد اضعف
لانهم تقليديين تقليدي بطبيعته ما يحب
التغيير اضافه الى عندهم التمسك التمسك
بتعاليم الكنيسه
الكنيسه يعني اللي يسمونه من الانجيليين
ترى الى وقت قريب كانوا يقولون الاجهاض
حرام ولكن الدوله لازم اطلع قوانية
لانه المفروض ان اللي يمنعك عن الاجهاض
والتزامك الديني وليس قانون الدوله الدوله
بعيده ما لها علاقه بالكنيسه وحنا لحال بس
بعدين غيره
من تطور البناء الى اناقه التصميم ورفاهيه
الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول سكنيه مبتكره
ومستدامه مع شركه صفاء للاستثمار المزيد
في وصف الحلقه
[موسيقى]
طيب وش الاشياء في ذلك الوقت ايش الاشياء
العامه اللي اسسوا عليها الدوله في
البدايه يعني ترى كانت اول اول ما تاسست
الدوله كانوا طاوله
وكان في صراع بين المستعمرات لانه كان في
تخوف من سيطره بعض المستعمرات على نفوذ
اكثر بالتالي سيطره على الحكومه
الفيدراليه هي اكبر مستعمره من اكبر ولايه
كلام من 13 ولايه
عدد السكان فكان يقول كذا
بيصير لها سلطه اكبر لا هذه مشكله يعني
شيء يخيف الولايات الاصغر فكانت دائما
المشاكل تدور حول الموضوع هذا وحول التدخل
الخارجي كان يعني عندهم هاجس التدخل
الخارجي لانهم كانوا وهذا شيء صحيح
الخارجي من التدخل والدول الاوروبيه وهمهم
بس كيف كيف نحمي انفسنا وكيف نبني انفسنا
فاول صراع ظهر عندهم كان بين
الفيدراليستون
حزب يرى انه لا بد انه الحكومه الفيدراليه
تكون قويه لانك تبغى تاسستها ولا لازم
الدوله هذه تكون قويه الطرف الثاني يقول
لا الحكومه الفيدراليه لازم تكون ضعيفه
يعني يمكن اشبه بمكتب تنسيق
كل الولايات لازم يكون عندها استقلاليه
اعلى
بعدين تغيرت الاحزاب وتغيرت الافكار
واستمرتها دائما عندها حزبين الرئيس في
هذا الوقت
يعني كان في عندنا البيض من اوروبا سود من
افريقيا وفي السكان الاصليين وبدي اعرف
المجتمعات الموجوده كان في امريكا لانه
بدت الهجره لها متاخره يعني اول مستعمرات
ما بدات الا في 1607 اكبر هجره جيت
لامريكا كانت بين
1700 يمكن 1800
يعني من 1720 الى 1820 هذه اللي كانت يعني
ارتفع فيها عدد السكان بشكل كبير وما
كانوا انجليزي كانوا جايين من مختلف دول
اوروبا
في مناطق في امريكا اليوم تعرف ان هذه
المنطقه هولنديه المنطقه هذه المانيه شوف
اسماء الاسماء يعني المعالم الاوديه
والجبال والانهار والمدن شوفوا كلها مثلا
بالالماني وتلقى عندهم يعني يمكن بعض
السكان ما زال الملامح اكثر بالشكل هذا
وفي الهولنديين كلهم مناطق الصينيين كلهم
وجود كبير
الصينيين كانوا من اوائل الناس
ولكنهم كانوا يشوف في مجتمعات منغلقه باي
علاقه يعني منفصلين تماما لدرجه انه كانوا
يعني يجي لامريكا ويعيش فيها ويموت فيها
وما يعرف ما يعرف انجليزي اصلا
اللي هم قياداتهم قياداتهم هذه اللي
تتعامل مع الامريكان غير كده
كانوا يعني
يعتبرون مواطنين درجه ثانيه ما لهم سجلات
الجرائم ضدهم ما يعني بجديه طبعا في وقتها
كانت امريكا كلها يعني خصوصا انها كانت
تتوسع فخصوص المناطق الجديده اللي توهم
بادين ينشئون فيها مدن مستعمراتكم فيها
الامل
بس كان على السنين اكثر من غيرهم وخصوصا
مع فروه الذهب لانهم مع توسع للغرب منطقه
الجبال اكتشفوا الذهب فصارت هجره يعني
هجره جماعيه كبيره من الشرق للغرب بحث عن
الذهب والصينيين راحوا معهم وكانوا في كل
مدن الذهب تلقى الصالون حقاره
والصينيين عشان يقدمون اللحوم ومن اللحوم
الجزائريين هذه شغلهم
كانوا متواجدين بكل المدن
المكسيكان المكسيكان كانوا بايدين
المكسيكان لفتره متاخره جو مع انتشار
الرعي
بدو يجون لانه اصلا تكساس
واريزونا نيومي
ولكنها ما كانت مستعمرتها يعني داخل ضمن
حدودها ولكن مهملتها لان مناطق بعيده
وفقير ولا حد يجيها يعني اول استعمر فيها
كانون
من حاكم المكسيك وقتها انه حنا نبغى ننشئ
مستعمره وسمح لهم وسووا بعدين استقلت
تكساس ما استقلت من المكسيك الى 1845
يعني الى 150 سنه تبع المكسيك تبع المكسيك
الرسميه يعني استقلت بحرب
طيب اذا نرجع للتاسيس جورج واشنطن ما كان
كان هو اول رئيس بدون حزب كان مستقل
والدستور لا ينص على وجود احزاب فمتى نشات
الحساب
الاحزاب نشات بعد الحزمه
انه يعني في ناس كذا ولكن كيحسب تنظيم
مظهره بعد
رئاسه واشنطن اثناء رئاسه واشنطن حتى
واشنطن
واشنطن كان وقعت الجيش في الحرب فلما
انتصروا في الحرب قالوا حنا رافض الرئاسه
يقول انا انا اصلح عقود الجيش بس ما اصلح
للرئاسه قالوا لا انت الوحيد اللي عليك
جمعتن حنا تونا الحين ما عندنا يعني ما
عندنا اي نظام ما عندنا اي شيء انت تقوم
عليك يا جماعه من كل الناس نبيك رئيس فمسك
الرئاسه قالوا اربع سنوات
مسك الاربع سنوات في نهايه الاربع سنوات
كانت الاحزاب تشكلت وبدات المشاكل تزيد
بين الفيدراليست لدرجه انه خاف انه لو ما
ترشح مره ثانيه للرئاسه انه ممكن تقوم حرب
بينهم
فبقي فتره ثانيه على اساس يضمن انه ما
يصير حرب بعد الفتره الثانيه قال لا خلاص
ما راح اجدد اكثر من كذا وترك الرئاسه
وصارت انتخابات طبعا حتى في فتره ثانيه
صارت الانتخابات بس كانت يعني انتخابات
معروفه من الفايز فيها يعني
ليش كان ليش اغفل الدستور وجود الاحزاب
وتنظيمها
هو كان يعني كان في خلاف بين كتبت الدستور
على موضوع الاحزاب كانوا يعني فريق يقول
الاحزاب هذولي شر لازم ما يكون عندنا
احزاب لازم نمنع الاحزاب الفريق الثاني
كان يقول كويسه ولكنها شر لا بد منها لازم
يكون فيها احزاب لانها ضروره بغض النظر عن
المساواها ممكن عندهم مخاوف من الاحزاب
مخاوف من الحرب الاهليه مخاوف من التدخل
الخارجي كانوا يخشون انه يتم تدخل خارجي
عن طريق تكوين علاقات مع الاحزاب هذه
والسيطره عليها وبالتالي تكوين نفوت داخل
البلد من الدول الكبرى فكان عندهم تخوف من
الثنتين هذولي بشكل كبير فعشان كذا كانوا
عندهم تحفظ على موضوع الاحزاب ما يعني بس
انه ما اتفقوا على انه لازم نسوي احزاب
ولا تبقوا على انه الاحزاب لابد انها تمنح
فتشكلت بشكل طبيعي بعد بعد
نهايه الحرب بعد الاستقلال بس والشكل
الدوله بدون حساب
كيف بيكون يعني
تتذكر انك تتكلم عن دوله صغيره عباره عن
يعني مدن صغيره فيها اعداد صغيره من
السكان فكانوا يتخيلون انه يكون عندك
ويكون عندك مسؤولين محليين ومسؤولين
المحليين هدول هم اللي يديرون البلد بدون
اجندات سياسيه ما ضروري يكون عنده سياسيه
كبيره وانت اصلا ما انت بحاجه الاجنده
وطنيه على مستوى الوطن بالكامل على مستوى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لانه عاملين
فرقو صغير ودول صغيره بس بعد كده لا
بدون وجود منظمات
تستطيع افراز القاده ما تقدر تجدد في
الطبقه السياسيه لازم الاحزاب تبدا تفرس
لك القاده وتبدا يعني
او تصنع التوجهات لما تقول صغيره
صفر هذا يعني انا اعتقد انه كان وقت
الاستقلال كان عدد سكان اربعه مليون
يعني انا ماني متاكد من الرقم
الذاكره يعني يقول لك في الهجره هذه اللي
تكلمنا عنها من 1700 الى 1800 كان مجموع
المهاجرين يعني يعد على اصابع اليد
بالملايين يعني مليونين ثلاث ملايين ثوره
في عدد سكان امريكا اضافه الى انه ما كان
عندهم امكانيات يعني غالبيه المهاجرين
كانوا ناس ميتين من الجوع يدورون فرص
جديده ما هو ناس جايين بقوه جايين
باستثمرات غالبيتهم جايين يدورون فرص
جديده ميتين من الجوع فقراء بعضهم حرفيين
وبعضهم ما عندهم حتى مهانه فما كانت
الدوله عندها ذكر امكانيات اصلا
وما اكتشفت الموارد الهائله اللي طلعت
بعدين يعني عندك البترول وعندك القطن
وعندك التبغ هذه اسست لقوه لامريكا بعدين
لانها كانت موارد اساسيه اعتمد عليها
العالم كله يعني بالذات البترول وقت الحرب
العالميه كان اقوى في امريكا يوم ظهرت
الاحزاب هل ظهرت
كحلف واتحاد سياسي ولا كانت
خلف افكار ايدولوجيه معينه هي كانت هي
كانت تحالف سياسي
لترويجات معينه انه انا ارى انه لازم يكون
الحكومه الفيدراليه تكون قويه ويكون عندها
سلطه وتكون يعني
تستطيع ان تفرض ارادتها
هذا يقول لا وهذا كله هذه سياسيه في
النهايه حتى اختلفوا في النهايه ممكن كان
فيها ليبراليه محافظين هذه ظهرت بعدين
ما ظهرت على طول وكان وما كان فيه الفصل
اللي حنا نشوفه اليوم يعني اليوم عندنا
فصل تام انه الليبراليون كلهم في الحزب
الديمقراطي والمحافظين كلهم بالحزب
الجمهوري هذا ما صار الا بالعهد يعني
بالتاريخ الحديث
الين الحرب الاهليه يعني من بعد الحرب
الاهليه بالذات كان الحزب الجمهوري والحزب
الليبرالي والحزب الديمقراطي هو الحزب
المحافظ وكانوا يعني لانه كان
كان جمهوري وكان هو اللي يقود الحرب باسم
الحزب الجمهوري كان الحزب الجمهوري وحزب
الشمال الحزب الديمقراطي وحزب الجنوب فلما
انتهت الحرب استمر الحزب الديمقراطي في
غالبيه ممثلين وجايين من الولايات
الجنوبيه مهزومه في الحرب وجمهوريين من
الشمال
حتى كان في مقوله
كان يعني كان رئيس امريكا بدايه القرن
العشرين
كان يعني يسب فيها الليبراليين
ما ذكر النصه حرفيا
كان يتكلم عن حزب الجمهوري عن حزمه لانه
اختلف معهم لانه كان وقتها مسموح للرئيس
ترشح اكثر من مره ولما جاي ترشح مره ثانيه
ترشح بس قالوا انا ما رحت ترشح مره ثانيه
بس مره ثانيه قالوا اوكي
بترشح مره ثالثه ورفضوا الحزب فقام رشح
نفسه مع حزب ثالث وخسر
بسبهم فكان يسب الليبراليين كانت اغلبيه
الليبراليين في الحزب الجمهوري واغلبيه
المحافظين في الحزب الديمقراطي الي فتره
فتره الستينات
بدا اول شيء مع لندن جونسون لما وقع قانون
حقوق اللي هي حقوق المدنيه المساواه في
الحقوق المدنيه ما بين السود والبيض هذا
كانت يعني قفزه قفزها الحزب الديمقراطي من
المحافظه للابراليه كانت خطوه كبيره اتجاه
اليسار انه هذا حزب الجنوب هذا حزب
العنصريين حزب هذا اللي يعني
تاريخ اسود
الديمقراطيين في الجنوب لهم تاريخ اسود
بعد الحرب الاهليه مع العنصريه حتى بعد ما
نهايه الحرب حتى بعد ما خسروا وكانوا لهم
اساليب قدره كانت في الكونغرس
للمحافظه على العنصريه في قوانين كثير
يسمع عنها اي واحد يقرا مثلا في التاريخ
الامريكي مثلا
هذه كانت قوانين لانه بعد ما انتهت الحرب
الاهليه انتصر الشمال على الجنوب فرض على
الجنوب جبرا انه السود يتحررون وانهم
يصيرون يشتغلون وانهم يصيرون في
الانتخابات طبعا موضوع التصويت الانتخابات
كان عليه خلاف لانه جاء تعديل دستوري في
وقت من الاوقات بس قبل لا يجي التعديل
الدستوري كان عليه خلاف
فصاروا يطلعون قوانين
يحاولون يحدون فيها من الحقوق اللي تمنح
للسوق يجي مثلا يقول لك انت تبي انتخابات
لازم تقرا تكتب
بحكم ان الصوت اغلبهم عماله ما يعرفوا
من التصويت في الانتخابات لازم يكون عندك
املاك
ما تكون يعني عامل تبي تصوت في الانتخابات
لازم تدفع ضريبه والضريبه هذه ما يقدر
يدفعها العامل فكل هذه كانت قوانين موجهه
نحو منع الصود من التصويت وكان يسمونها
هذه كلها الديمقراطيه ومرروها يعني كانوا
يمرون على مستوى الولايات وكانوا احيانا
يمرون يمررون كثير من الكونجرس بالضغط
بصفقات مع الجمهوريين
يعني مقابل عمل السياسي
شدوا جذب
مثل ما قلت لك 1960
1960 لما جاءت 1960 كان الجمهوريين هم
الليبراليين
الاغلبيه اغلبيه الليبراليين في الحزب
الجمهوري واغلبيه في الحزب الديمقراطي
منهم المحافظين في امريكا المحافظين حنا
عندنا يعني نوعين من المحافظه اللي هي
المحافظه الاجتماعيه والمحافظه الاقتصاديه
المحافظه الاجتماعيه اللي هي يعني الاسره
والحشمه والى اخره المحافظه الاقتصاديه
اللي هي دوله صغيره قوانين محدوده ضرائب
قليله
حكومه صغيره ضرائب محدوده وقوانين محدوده
ان كانت تعطي للسوق مجاله طبعا
الفروقات النسبيه دائما ما بين الامريكان
النسبيه كلهم يؤمنون بالسوق الحر وكلهم
يؤمنون يعني بمبدا التنافسيه ولكنه هذول
يبغون تجديد اكثر وهذا يبون تشديد اقل
خدمات حكوميه اكثر
حكوميه اقل بينما كلهم مجمعين على انه
الحكومه لازم تقدم كل الخدمات الاساسيه
ولازم تقدمها مستوى جيد بس ايه الخلافات
النسبيه فالمحافظين يرون خدمات اقل
والضرائب اقل وتشديد اكثر في الجانب
الاجتماعي الليبراليين العكس تماما يعني
يبغون حكومه اكبر خدمات افضل حتى لو اضطر
يدفع ضرائب اكثر اضافه الى حريه اجتماعيه
اعلى
فالجمهوريين هم الليبراليين الديمقراطيين
هم المحافظين 1960 جاء
الديمقراطي كان هو نائب حق شو اسمه
فلما صار هو الرئيس
استلم الحكم
من تكساس من كانت تكساس وقتها عقل
الديمقراطيين كانت يعني ولايه ديمقراطيه
الديمقراطيه
فكان هو الرئيس الوحيد اللي يقدر يوقع
قانون زي هذا
وماذا ويظل عنده عمل في الانتخابات
وقع القانون
كانت نقله كبيره
اليمين الى اليسار لحزب الديمقراطي جاء
بعدها قضيه
لانه وقع اي قانون قانون الحقوق المدنيه
اللي عطى حقوق مساواه ما بين البيض
والصدود قال ممنوع من المدارس تكون مفصوله
ممنوع من الباصات تكون مفصول وممنوع ان
المطاعم تكون مفصوله لازم كل شيء متساوي
القانون هذا كانت بعد يعني كانت حركه
شعبيه ضخمه وكانت يعني لها تاريخ طويل
لحركه الحقوق المدنيه شاركوا فيها السود
واليهود بدرجه كبرى
بعد ما توقع القانون هذا
صارت فيه نقله من الديمقراطيين
اليسار بعد كده
اول شيء النائب
الدافع عند الديمقراطيين يعني
الفصل كان ينظر له كمشكله لانه في ظلم
ولكنه في ناس
الديمقراطيين يفترض انهم هم اللي يمثلون
الناس اللي يقولون لا مو بظلم يفترض
فكانوا يقولون انه لا يعني في توجه انه
حنا لابد نتخذ الخطوه هذه لانه الوضع هذا
غير صحيح هذه النظره المثاليه النظره
المسرحيه تقول انهم لا يقولون حنا ما راح
نقدر نستمر كحزب سياسي قوي الا اذا جذبنا
السود وما
نقدرنا القانون هذا لو مره القانون هذا
خلاص معنا طول عمرهم وفعلا السود من
الستينات الى اليوم يصوتون بنسب يعني
كاسحه صالحه الديمقراطيين
فما دخلت بعقولهم
طب بالنسبه للجمهوريه بما انهم كانوا هم
اللي انهو العبوديه انهو كان موقفهم ما
كان عندهم موقف واضح ضد
القانون حقوق المدنيه
ولكنهم هم جت مشكلتهم بعدها بفتره قصيره
لانه قضيه نفسهم بعد اقل من عشر سنوات
وقضيه يعني سببت حرف كبير في الجمهوريين
لانه شو اللي صار
في البدايه النائب حقه ودين بفساتهم
وصلوا معه المدعين انه خلاص احنا ما راح
نحاكم ما راح ندخلك السجن ولكن انت تستقيل
وتعتزل سياسه
[موسيقى]
فاستقال وعزل تماما ونحط على الرف وجابوا
مكانه مين جابوا بورتو
لما طلعت فضيحه الاصدقائنا يعني كان امام
خيارين يستقيل يعزل فقر فضلا يستقيم
كان فيه وجهه نظر الجمهوريه خلاص
يعني راس الحزب اكتشف انه فاسد فساد كبير
بعد يعني فساد سياسي كبير
وكانت العمليه اخذت فتره طويله من
التحقيقات والفضائح المتتاليه والمشاكل
المتتاليه اللي نزلت شعبيه فكان يعني
السؤال هل بيموت الحزب وبيطلع الحزب ثاني
بداله ولا لا هذا كان سالفته يفوز
بالرئاسه
مو بالحين مو بالحين يعني الحين هل يموت
ولا ما يموت وقتها
كامل كل الحزب الجمهوري وقتها فورد فورد
كان جاي بموافقه الديمقراطيين لانه كان
اللي يصوت التعديل 25 للدستور
لما يعني يفضى اللاعب الرئيس
فاتفقوا جمهوريه معك الديمقراطيين انه
احنا بنجيب لكم واحد توافقون عليه من
توافقون عليه توافقون على فورد قالوا ايه
يعتبر رئيس توافقي الى حد كبير ومرضيا
عليه يوم اجاب اصلا فيفترض انه ممكن يكون
قادر على جذب اصوات ومع ذلك خسر
الانتخابات وخسروا الانتخابات قدام واحد
يعني كان ينظر له
مجددا ومحافظ جدا وتقليدي جدا وما كان وما
كان معروف يعني لما بدا حمله الانتخابيه
يعني
خلاص الحزب الجمهوري انت
تماما فطلعت تيار داخل الحزب الجمهوري كان
لحظه
الديمقراطيين
ليش ما نستقطبهم احنا
وقتها طلعوا
بسحبهم من الديمقراطيين نبي نسحب الديمقرا
للمحافظين للحزب الديمقراطي انهم يعيدون
حزب الجمهوري نبي نطرح مشاكلهم ونطرح
مطالبهم بحيث اننا نجذبهم
وخصوصا انه وقتها بدو الانجيليين كانوا
يعني الى فتره كارتر وهم يرون ان السياسه
وسخ
انها تلوثك انت كرجل دين لما تدخل في
السياسه ان تتلوث فما كانوا يتكلمون في
السياسه نهائيا ولا يؤيدون اي حزب ولا اي
دون اي احد كانوا الفئه هذه منعزله تماما
عن السياسه نسبه تمارين يعني
لاسباب تتعلق بقوانين طلعت ايام مثلا ايام
طلع قانون يقول انه اي منظمه عندها اعفاء
ضريبي
لانها منظمه دينيه او خيريه او تظهر اذا
كان عندك اعفاء ضريبي وكان عندك ممارسات
عنصريه
لانه وقتها كان الى حد ما يسمح
يعني الجهات الخاصه انها تحط بعض
الممارسات العنصريه ما كانت القوانين
بالدقه والتفصيل التي تشمل كل شيء
منظمات كان عندها عنصريه عاليه في موضوع
الزواج
كان بعضهم اصلا يرفض دخول السود نهائي
للمنظمات حقتهم وبعضهم يقبل بدخول السود
ولكنه يرفض موضوع الزواج المختلط كان
الزواج المختلط هذا جريمه وكان اي احد
يعني يصير علاقه بين اولاده وبنت
من اعراق مختلفه
فكانت هذه لو طبق القانون عليهم بيرفع
عنهم
المؤسسات هذه بشكل كبير لانه بيصير عليه
ضرائب عقار ضرائب رواتب يعني نسب عاليه من
الضرائب بيتحملها فقلب عليهم يعني ايوه
فاهم يوم صار الشيء هذا
يعني صار ضد كارتر
الجمهوريين تبنوا قضاياهم بشكل مباشر ورغم
انه جمهوريه وقتها كانوا يرشحوا منك كانوا
يعني يعتبر ممثل جاي من هوليود
ومع ذلك راحوا قدروا يجذبهم لانه كان
طرحوا يميني جدا كان هو للسحب الحزب
الجمهوري لليمين بطرحه وطاروا مع جمهوريه
باليمين وقدروا يطلع كارتر من الرئاسه
ياخذ فكان هذا يعني اعاد احياء الحزب
الجمهوري من جديد من يومها
[موسيقى]
اليمين المتدين والحزب الجمهوري ملتصقين
والحزب الجمهوري وقتها زاد ناحيه اليمين
اكثر هنا الديمقراطيين بداوا يقولون احنا
لازم نطهر صفوفنا من المحافظين لانه
المحافظين يمثلون ارث سيء للحزب
الديمقراطي هم اللي طلعوا قوانين جيم كروم
وهم اللي طلعوا كل كل التاريخ الاسود حق
الحزب الديمقراطي سووا المحافظين فاحنا
لازم نطهر الحزب من بقايا المحافظين اللي
ما زالوا موجودين فيه فصارت فيه يعني صارت
فيه عمليه اخراجهم عن طريق الانتخابات
الاوليه ومن الانتخابات الاوليه وكذا يعني
الين طلعوهم بالكامل طبعا راحوا لجمهوريين
الى وقت قريب قبل العشرين ثلاثين سنه كان
فيه اقليه
الليبراليه في الحزب الجمهوري واقليه
محافظه في الحزب الديمقراطي الحين خلاص ما
عاد فيه يعني يمكن تلقى لك اسم ولا اسمين
يعني مثلا مع الديمقراطيين مع الجمهوريين
بس طيب لما نقول يمين يسار مين اللي مين
من اليسار في امريكا طبعا اليمين اللي هو
الجمهوريين واليسار الديمقراطيين ولكن
المشكله انه مصطلح اليسار يستخدم يعني
مختلفه يعني يقول لك على كل من يسار الوسط
معتدل اي احد يسار الاعتدال بشوي خلاص
يعتبر يسار بعدين في ناس ثانيين يقول لك
لا انت عندك الليبراليين اذا عندكم تقدمين
اللي هم بعدين عندك
اشتراكيه صار متطرف
يسار ممكن تقول لا تصف الا من التقدمين
وطالع وهذا الاغلب يعني انت لما تصير
تتكلم بشكل عام عاده يقول لك للتسهيل يمين
يسار يتكلم بالتفصيل اذا قال يسار معناته
يقصد من التقدمين طالع واليمين فيه نفس
هذا الطيف ايه نفس الشيء في المعتدلين
بعدين في عندنا
المتشددين والمتشددين فئات يعني
الديمقراطيين انت يمكن تتكلم على التدرج
الجمهوريين عندهم التدرج اقل ولكن عندهم
تفرع لانهم عندهم القضيه الواحده في
ناخبين عندهم وعندهم مشرعين اهتماماتهم
محصوره باشياء معينه ما يهم اي شيء ثاني
في متدينين وفي حق
الاجهاض وغدروا غالبا يكونون هم المبتدئين
نفسهم عندك حقين السلاح عندك حقين العسكر
انه لازم الجيش يكون اقوى شيء في الدنيا
ولازم ما تقول له شيء تكب عليه فهذولي
فئات عاده
يكون متشدد في الجزئيه هذه بس مو متشدده
في جزئيات ثانيه فصعب انك تقول انه اكثر
يميت رغم انه فعلا متجدد وفي طبعا اليمين
المتطرف هذولي شاطحين بكل طيب
عاده اليمين متطرفين يشطح في ايش اليمين
المتطرف عنده عنصريه
عندهم اطروحات فيها
يعني
هم مش مشكلتهم مشكلتهم انهم يلجاون
للتخويف
لاكتذاب الناخبين فتلقاه هو تروح وتوفي
الاصل تروحوا عنصريه هو يرى انه انا عندنا
الاغلبيه البيضاء قاعده تخسر حقوقها
والحقوق هذه لازم تشترك
ولكنه كيف ما هو بالضروري انه يقنعك
بالشيء هذا ممكن ما يطرح الموضوع هذا
نهايه يبدا يتكلم على موضوع امور دينيه
يبدا يتكلم على امور اقتصاديه يبدا يتكلم
على امور اخلاقيه يبدا يتكلم عن امور
امنيه على موضوع الجرائم والشرطه
يكونون متشددين جدا في الاطروحات هذه بهدف
التخويف ادعم جدته الاساسيه ولا هم اليمين
عندهم الحكومه اصغر حكومه ممكنه
اكبر تدخل ممكن في المجتمع يعني اقل تدخل
ممكن في الاقتصاد واكبر تدخل ممكن في
المجتمع هذا اقصى اليمين افكاره وقت
اليسار اقصى اليسار عندك طبعا
لازم يعاد تشكيل امريكا فكريا من جديد
يعني حنا يقول لك انه ما يكفي انك تقول
انه العنصريه متاصله في الثقافه الامريكيه
عبر اجيال لا يجب انك تقول الثقافه
الامريكيه كلها خطا لانها مبنيه على
العنصريه فبالتالي لازم يعود بناها من
جديد
مشكلتهم انه طرحهم هذا رغم انه في بعض
جزئيات
وفي جزء
ولكن الباكج كلها ترى انك تبي تسوي قطيعه
مع مصالح امريكا مع حلفاء امريكا مع بنائك
الداخلي مع مؤسساتك الداخليه
وعندهم تناقضات يعني يقول لك انت مثلا
لازم يكون عندك حريه لازم كل واحد يسوي
حريه في الطرح بعدين يبدا يهاجم يخالفه
يقول لازم تمنع من الطرحه شلون تمنع من
الطرح فعندهم التناقضات هذه لانه دائما
المتطرف انتو متناقضات ولكنه الاقليه
الديموقراطي صغيره
يعني حتى التقدميين التقدميين فيهم فئه
متطرفه
اتاكد في مرحله التطبيق انه لا يكون في
التطبيق في عنصريه مخفيه طبعا احنا نتكلم
عن جوانب كثيره العنصريه بس على اساس انها
مشتخذها كمثال فيعني كلام قد يكون مبالغ
فيه قد يكون صحيح في بعض جهاته ولكن قد
ترفضه قد تقبله ولكن تاخذه تعطي معه تقدر
تعطي معهم لانهم يعني وحتى عندهم نظره
فوقيه يعني انا اصلا انا وصلت للحقيقه
المطلقه وانت ما تعرف شيء انت تروح تتعلم
وتعرف الحقيقه المطلقه زي ما انا سويت
عشان تجي تقيدني ولا انت اصلا وهم اقليه
يعني اقل من
من الامريكان
من الديمقراطيين اذا بتاخذ اقصى
مع هذول يجون 15% عشره الى 15% بينما لما
تروح باليمين اذا بتاخذ اقصى اليمين
للمتشددين يوصلون اعلى حوالي 30%
التطرف عند الجمهوريين اعلى من التطرف عند
الديمقراطيه لاسباب
تاريخيهما اكثر تطرفا
واكثر تطرفا مثل ما قلنا يعني تطرفهم اعلى
ووزنهم داخل الحزبه اعلى لانه الحزب الحزب
الجمهوري لما قلنا مع ريجن اكتسح ريجن
يعني في اول انتخابات في ثمانين فاس لما
جاي اعاده انتخابه 49 ولايه
كثير من الولايات اللي كانت تعتبر يعني
فئات في المجتمع اللي هم يسمونهم
بالبلوكولر اللي هم عمال المصانع بالدرجه
الاولى والوظائف المشابهه لها
الديمقراطيين باخلاص على اساس موضوع
الاتحادات العماليه لانه كان مؤيدين حقوق
العمال كلهم
الاكتساح هذا خلد الديمقراط يوقف لحظه
انا لازم اعيد حساباتي ما اقدر اعيش في
الوضع هذا خصوصا كان ما زال عنده مغربيه
لانه كان اغلبيه مجلس النواب عندهم
بس طيب الحين انا هل اروح يسار ولا اروح
يمين لما يجي المرشح السياسي يفكر انا لما
اجي اقنع واحد من اليسار هذا يا بسوت لي
فبالتالي انا لما اقنعه بس لما اروح
لليمين
بصوت المنافسه انا لما اقرعه
فصاروا الديمقراطين يروحون جهه اليمين
طبعا انت لما تكون في اليسار تروح في
اليمين في النهايه يمكن تعتدل
الجمهوريه اكثر لانه الديمقراطيه صاروا
ياكلون الاعتدال هم راحوا يتبنون قضايح
قلنا الاجهاض قضايا حق السلاح قضايا الدين
يتبنون قضاياهم لانه يقول لك هذولي ناخذ
قضيه واحده ما يهمون القضيه هذه ما راح
اخسره مهما كانت توجهات الثانيه فخليني
اعطيه الموضوع حقه هذا وامشي بعد فتره
اكتشفوا انه قاعدتهم تاكلت
فصاروا المتطرفين ينزلون نسبه عاليه من
القاعده هذه
بينما عند الديمقراطيين لانه كانوا يسحبون
يعني الديمقراطيين من من منتصف الثمانينات
بداوا على شوي شوي وهم يسحبون يمين
اثناء فتره بوش بوش الابن بالذات بدء
التفكير وكان اول مظهر عملي لها
اوباما كان يعتبر يعني اكثر يمينيه منه
اكثر اعتدال منه فكان ترشيح اوباما وعقبه
جالسه انه يكتسح فكان في زحف رجع شوي
لليسار لو تجي الافكار ريجن ريجن يعني
اللي قلنا انه هو السحب الجمهوريه نحو
اليمين يعني الاقصى اليمين افكاره لو
تطرحه اليوم كان هذا الليبرالي
هذا مو جمهوري هذا كذاب
افكار اللي كانت تعتبر اقصى اليمين اليوم
صار معتدله
بالمقابل
الجهتين ولكنه كان لليمين اكثر بكثير
وهذا التطرف عالي
المشكله انت لما تكون قاعدتك متطرفه جريئه
لانك انت عشان تفوز في الانتخابات لازم
اول اول حزب فاذا ما ارضيت هذول ما يرشمات
اصلا ما تدخل في المنافسه
وصوتهم يعني من ناحيه الديمقراطيين
الديمقراطيين الفئه المتطرفه اغلبهم بيض
متعلمين ذوي دخل عالي ويسكنوا في المدن
الكبيره هذا كله يوفر عندهم امكانياته
عاليه للصوت العالي
فصوتهم عالي ضجيجهم عالي تحس انهم صوتهم
طاقي على كل شيء ولكنهم فعليا اقليه وعشان
كذا ترى دائما
حتى لما تجي لما تشوف مثلا شوف من ايام
اوباما صار اكثر من تمرد داخل الجمهوريين
على قيادتهم كدايره اليمين اقصى اليمين
على القياده ويسقطها احيانا كثيره اخرتها
مكارتي يقدم لهم تنازلات كبيره جدا عشان
يصير
رئيس المجلس الديمقراطيه لا تمر بجم الوسط
لانه اليسار يعرف انه ضعيف ما يقدر ما
يقدر يتبرد اصلا مهمهم بس
ويعطوني مقعد على الطاوله اوكي بينما
الوسط لا يرى انه عنده القوه
طيب ليش فيه
الولايات تتبع مثلا ولايه جمهوريه في
ولايات ديمقراطيه بسبب تكون هذه ليس
لولايه تصبح تبع
ايه لو لاحظت الشيء هذه تغير من الوقت
يعني الولايات يتغير
ميولها على حسب تاريخ يعني لما تكلمنا
عنها
فالحين ما حد يتخيل انه اي ديمقراطيه ممكن
يفوز باي مسابقه على مستوى الولايه يعني
يفوزون باشياء محليه مقاعد في الكونغرس
على مقاطعات محليه بس انا ما حد يفكر
الموضوع هذا
[موسيقى]
بينما الى فتره كانوا فيها الجمهوريه كان
يعني لهم لهم ثقل كبير فيها ما كانت ميؤوس
منها زي اليوم فالتغير هذا احيانا يكون
تغير
بسبب تغير الاحزاب يعني احنا تكلمنا الحزب
الديمقراطي كمحافظ فكانوا تكساس ديمقرا
المحافظ يوم صار هو الليبرالي مع جمهوريه
لانه مو محافظين استمرار مع سياده
المحافظين احيانا يكون تغير بنفس الولايه
طب طبيعه سكان الولايه
في العقود الاخيره صار في انفصال جغرافي
المناطق ذات الكثافه السكانيه العاليه
تروح جهه اليسار
والمناطق ذات الكثافه السكانيه المنخفضه
تروح جهه اليمين فعشان كذا تشوف كل
الولايات لما تشوفها بقع زرقه وحولها
مساحه كبيره حمراء واذا نظرت لقيت 80% من
السكان
لانه في المدن الكبيره كلها بينما الارياف
كلها صوت الجمهوريين والنسبه كل ما لا
تزيد وتزيد بدرجه عاليه يعني
الجمهوريين اليوم يفوزون في الارياف بفرق
70 نقطه يعني تخيل هذا ياخذ 80% وهذا ياخذ
عشرين في الميه بس
بينما في المدن الجمهوريه تقول
الديمقراطيه 60 سبعين في المئه
في الوقت الحالي في الزمن الحالي العصر
العشرين اليوم
الولايات اللي فيها مدن يعني غالبيه
سكانها في المدن الكبيره اصبحت
الديمقراطيه بينما الولايات اللي اغلب
سكانها في ارياف وفي مدن صغيره اصبحت
جمهوريه عشان كذا كله الولايات الكبيره
الديمقراطيه بس مثلا فيها اربعه مدن من
اكبر في امريكا
يعني ان تتكلم عن تكساس تقريبا ثلث مساحه
المملكه يعني المساحه مهوله مهوله جدا
تقعد ثمان ساعات في السياره ما قطعتها
ففيها ارياف كميه ارياف كبيره فالرغم انك
منخفضه مدن صغيره لكن عددها كبير جدا
مجموعهم يوازي سكان المدن
يعني يوازنون
الفارق اللي في المدن فالا هل الاربع مدن
الكبيره في تكساس زرقاء كمدينه يعني اخر
مدينه صارت زرقاء
كانت الى تقريبا ايلين قبل الى قبل 2016
الى 2012 كانت
من 2016 وهي صايره زرقاء تماما بينما دلس
وسطي من زمان اوستن طبعا يعني
انها زرقا لدرجه
بس نفسك يعني حتى انا انا اتذكر اول ما
رحت
يعني مستحيل
يعني على مستوى مدينه
الجمهوري وهذا على مستوى الولايات كلها
يعني حتى لما تجي للولايات اللي حمراء مره
اذا نظرت تلقى المقاطعه اللي في العاصمه
او في المدينه الكبيره
فاضي
يمكن اكثر شوي يعني هذول حاره من حواري
نيويورك
مع ذلك المدينه الرئيسيه اللي فيها طيب
يطلع منها يعني مشكلتهم لانه ما عندهم لعب
كونغرس واحد فالتصويت على مستوى الولايه
فالمستحيل يطلع منها
الديمقراطيه ولكنه على مستوى المحلي لا
تلقى فيه
وفي عدد كبير في الارياف ولكنه مو كافي
للاكتساح الجمهوري ولكن الحزب الديمقراطي
في فلوريدا في السنوات الاخيره اداء مصري
يعني اداءه فاشل في تنفيذ الحملات
الانتخابيه
بس افكار لازم تواصل مع الناس وعمل على
الارض وشغل يبدو انهم عندهم خلل في
المنظومه حقتهم خلاهم يضعف تواصلهم مع
الناس بدرجه انهم صاروا يعني صارت الولايه
ما زالوا ترى الجمهورين ترى يفوزون بها
فريق نقطتين ثلاثه يعني فرق كبير ولكنه
صعبه جدا على الديمقراطيهم يجيبونها
بشكل جدي
بينما الجمهوريين يفوزون فيها بخمسه وست
نقاط بعد الديموقراطين يفكر فيها انه لا
ممكن لنا امل بس فلوريدا رغم انه الاقليات
والعقليات بالعاده ما الديمقراطين وهي
موجوده بكثره في
الاردن
فيها نسبه كوبيين والكوبيين هذول جايين
وعندهم عداء مع نظام كاسترو فيشوفون انه
الجمهوريين اكثر شراسه
في التعامل مع كاسترو فعشان كذا يحبون
يايدونه يعني بالنسبه هم فيهم اغلبيه يعني
فيهم نسبه ديمقراطيه لا باس بها ولكن هذا
يزيد من يعني بدل مثلا ما ياخذون
الديمقراطيين 70% ياخذون خمسين في المئه
ولا ستين في المئه بالشكل هذا اضافه الى
انه ترى
عندهم محافظه اجتماعيه عاليه ترى محافظه
اجتماعيا فبعضهم يصوت الاسباب دينيه يعني
عندهم هم
الغالبيه العظمى منهم كاثوليك
والمتدينين منهم يرون الجهاد حرام وانك
تصوت الواحد يقول ان الاجهاض انه كل واحد
يعني خيار شخصي هذا يخرج كلمته
فيهم فئه تذهب اليسار هذا وفيهم فئه
تذهب للمسار السياسي لمعارضه كوبا ومع ذلك
مناطقهم الديون يفوزون فيها اكثر
السود يصوتون بنسبه تتراوح ما بين 85 الى
95% مع الديمقراطيه
يعني
في فلوريدا تحديدا
لانه ترى مركزين في الجنوب
انت لما تطلع للبان هانتل البان هاندل هذه
هذه كانك في على باما ترى يعني ما يحتاج
يقول كان اذا كان لونك مودي لا تهدي
طيب
العمري الانتخابات الاخيره 54%
من الجيل الالفيه صوت الديمقراطي
33%
ليش اغلب الشباب
عندنا دائما في تقسيم العمري والتقسيم
العلمي
يمر فيه بثلاث مراحل العمري والعلمي لا
كلهم لهم مسارهم فعاده
الديمقراطيين طرحهم مثالي
يطرحون مثاليات كثيره ومثاليات مغريه
والمثاليات تجذب صغار السن
لانهم ناس يقول لك انا طالع يا اخي انا
طالع في المدرسه مع اي واحد مكسيكي معي
واحد هندي ومعي ورابع ومبسوطين وده تقعد
تقول لي حقوق البيض مع حقوق البيض واخذه
منه بس يشوفون احيانا يعني يشوفون احيانا
ممارسات عنصريه
يشوف مثلا هو
هو تمسكه الشرطه يعني مستعمل
المخدراتهم بينما خويه اللي معه يمكن في
المدرسه ولا هذا ماسكينه ومدينه للسجن
ماخذ سابق
فيصير عنده رده الفعل هذه ويصير عنده
والاعجاب بالطرح المثالي حق الديمقراطيه
مع الديمقراطيه
بعدين تجي المرحله الثانيه
خصوصا من يتخرج منهم يعني من تخصصات
احترافيه احترافيه يعني نتكلم عن المهندس
محاسب طبيب محامي هذولي عاده يبدا يكون
اسره يكون عمله مرتبط بالمؤسسات الكبيره
لانه يشتغل في شركه كبيره الراتب التقاعدي
يحبه محطوط في صندوق مستثمر في السوق
الاسهم ومدخرات ومستثمرها بسوق الاسهم
فبالتالي ارتباطه بالسوق باسواق المال
والمنظمات الكبيره قوي كل ما تحسنت اوضاع
الشركات هذه هو تحسن وضعه ينعكس هذا عليه
بشكل مباشر وهذي كلها سياسه الجمهوريه
جمهوريين هم اللي يدعمون خلي الشركات تسوي
واعطها اكبر تخفيضات ضريبيه واعطها اكبر
امتيازات تجي النقطه الثانيه غالبا يكون
شكل اسره تزوج وصار عنده ولد ولا ولدين
يروحون للمدرسه
بدات تهمه المحافظات الاجتماعيه
بخاف على عيالي خاف على التاثير السيء
اللي يجي عليهم اخاف على امن اسرتي فيبدا
يمين للجمهوريين اكثر اذا كملت تعليمه
واخذ ماجستير الدكتوراه غالبا يرجع
الديمقراطي مره ثانيه
اصحاب الشهادات العلية يميلون دائما
المثقفين
والنخب واصحاب الشهادات العليا هذول
غالبيتهم الديمقراطيين بسبب مثاليه الطرح
الديمقراطي
[موسيقى]
طيب بالنسبه للمهاجرين اليوم نسبه
المهاجرين
تزيد في امريكا كم يمثلون من
اذا بتاخذ البيض طبعا هو المشكله في
اللاتينيين اللاتينين
يصنفون احيانا بيض وحين لا واحيانا يقسم
بعضهم بعضهم لا ولكن اذا بتاخذ اذا بتطلع
اللاتينين
اذا بتدخلوا العمل اللاتينين يوصلون 70%
طيب الان في عندنا
موجات تتغير انت رحت انه كانوا مثلا
المحافظين بعدين جاء اني الى عهد بعدين
خفت في التسعينات النسبيه ترى يعني عشان
ما يفهم المشاهده نتكلم تغير كبير وزحف
نسبي بس ما تشوف برضو المتغير بعد الالفيه
في صعود
لليسار كبير
وصعود داخل وخارج الحزب الديمقراطي لانه
الحزمه الديمقراطي كانوا دائما يقولون
احنا عشان نفوز لازم نكون معتدلين طلع
تيار يقول لا مو بلازم عشان تكون معتذرين
ممكن نكون تقدمين ونفوز بعد وحاولوا
يثبتون الشهاده واثبتوا
بدرجات نجاح متفاوته مو بشكل قاطع فهذا
اعطاهم شوي وزن زياده فعشان كذا في زحف
لليسار يعني وكل مثلا كل الحزبين مع مثلا
زواج المثليه
بالنسبه لزواج المثليه هذا ما يعتبر قضيه
خلافيه هو
فقط المشكله معها والجمهوريين يتبنون اراء
المتدينين في اشياء كثيره لذلك بعض
الجمهوريه يتبناه بس في جزئيه الزواج بس
ما هو في جزئيه العلاقات يقول لك لا
العلاقات كيف ولكن لو تلاحظوا الحين في
حمله قويه من اليمين ضد
كل الاشياء هذه
بحجج مختلفه
سبب الصعودة لانك لما تشوفها مثلا في
بدلايت ولا في صعود مؤخرا في مواجهه
اليسار هذه هذه الحرب الثقافيه اللي شغاله
في امريكا مشكله الحزب الجمهوري اللي
يعاني منها انه نتاكدت قاعدته نظريته
الاقتصاديه الاساسيه اللي يسمونها
تعتمد فكرتها على انه انا اعطي تخفيضات
ضريبيه وتسهيلات للشركات الشركات هذه يصير
عندها فلوس اكثر تتوسع اكثر توظف ناس اكثر
الناس هذه يصير عندها فلوس الاقتصاد كله
يتحرك وكله يتحسن النظريه هذه تعطلت خلاص
يعني في ناس يقولون بعض الاقتصاديين
يقولنا من الاساس اصلا ما تشتغل وفي ناس
يقول لك لا انها كانت شغاله في فترات
معينه بس مع العولمه ما عاد صارت شغاله
لانه توفر عندها فلوس تروح تستمرها مره ما
تستثمرها جوه فبالتالي ما في توسع
فالمفروض انك لا توجه التحسين للمواطن
بشكل مباشر تتخطى الشركات قادره على
منافسه تشتغل بنفسها معنى المسؤولين عن
توسعها
لانه هذه الجزئيه خلل الحدث وبسبه
يعني في جزء من الجمهوريين طلع من الحزب
بسبه ربه رفضا لترامب هذا زاد الطين بله
فانت ما عندك رساله اقتصاديه
وعندك قطاع رئيسي خسرته من عندك
والمتطرفين مسيطرين عليك ما انت قادر تطرح
اصلا اطروحات معتدله في اي شيء
فكان بس كيف انا بخلي الناس اول موضوع
الحرب الثقافيه لو تلاحظهم يعني من عشرين
عشرين عشرين وحتى مسارهم اللي متجه 24 كله
قائم على الحرب الثقافيه البحته فكره
الحرب الثقافيه اني انا اخذ اسوا ما عند
الطرف الاخر واضخمه باكبر درجه ممكنه
واضخه بترتيز على قاعده بحيث انهم يخافون
الطرف الاخر ما يقصر عنده اطروحات شاطحه
جدا ومقززه وغير مقبوله من غالبيه فئات
المجتمع فبالتالي يعني قاعد يقدم له شيء
فهدول ياخذون ويركزون عليه يعني انا اشوف
انا طبعا منقطع عن الاخبار
[موسيقى]
هذا يعني مطعم هذا تقليدي جدا
حاط يمكن هذا القوس قزح ولا شيء يعني في
في هجوم حاد على كل شيء واستعداء على كل
شيء بشراسه لانهم خايفين من دخول
الانتخابات الجايه
بدون رساله يبون يبون يعني يستخدمون الخوف
ليشتذاب الناخبين وجبوريين شاطرين جدا في
الاشياء هذه يعني الجمهوريين في تشكيل
الرساله واصالها للناخب فنانين سياسيه
مبدعين الديمقراطيين سيئين
الديمقراطيين ما يعرفون كيف يوصلوا
رسالتهم من الديمقراطيين عندهم
هاليود وهذه ولا انظروا
كل المسلسلات
بتلقى دق على اتحادات المدرسين انه مدرس
ما يفصل مهما سوى بتلقى دق على الضرائب
العاليه تلقى دق على شغل اداء الحكومه
كلها هذه مليانه من كل المسلسلات فبالتالي
ما هو يعني السيطره الظاهريه اكثر مما هي
فعليه الاعلام الاعلام اللي تعرض له
المواطن الامريكي يتعرض للاعلام المحلي
اكثر بكثير مما يتعرض للعلامه الوطني يعني
لما تتكلم الحين كل الكلام كل الهيلمان
على
مجموع مشاهديهم في اعلى ساعاتهم كلهم مع
بعض ما يكمل مليونين امريكا فيها 350
مليون خاصه
يعني
بشكل مكثف بعد لما تشوف الصحف المحليه
كثير من الصحف المحليه يمين يمين الاذاعات
كثير البرامج في برامج اذاعات يعني تسمع
بالملايين تنقل على مستوى الولايات كبيره
جدا بس عندك ام بي ار في الاخير
الا يعني فئات المثقفين والمتثاقين هذول
المثقفين فقط ولكنه فعليا ما هي منتشره
يعني
ولكن تعدادهم من المجتمع قليل قليل يعني
واذا ابتعدنا عن الدكاتره والباحثين ولا
زي كذا هذولي اذا جيت للطبقه العاديه تراك
كثير
يعني ممكن غير اذا شاف اني ناس معنقف يعني
فعلا
ما حد يشوفها وهي قناه نجحت جدا يعني مع
كثره القنوات الحين عندنا يا اخي
[موسيقى]
في قنوات على مستوى امريكا وفي قنوات على
المدينه بس اللون
طيب بالنسبه لي مثلا في الجمهوريه في
احصاء السنه الماضيه كان انه
48% منهم ما عنده مشكله مع المثليه بينما
ظهر 7% فقط اللي ما عنده مشكله مع
المتحولين جنسيا مش مشكله الجمهوريه
هنا هنا
اشتغلوا على موضوع
الشواذ على موضوع تطبيعه
وفي بعض الناس يعني يقول بدا يتقبل للفكره
بطريقه انه انا ماني الناس
انا عايش باسرتي مستقل وكل شيء نظيف وكل
شيء مرتب يا سلام
بدت الفكره هذه يعني شوي تحقق
وخصوصا بين الفئات الصغيره وبدت تدخل حتى
على الاسر المحافظه
انه صار الاسره المحافظه بدا بعضها يتقبل
مع انه ترى هذا الكلام فقط في المدن
الكبيره فضواحيها فقط ترى
هذا يوم صار تقبل هذا بدات مشكله ثانيه لا
انا طيب كيف اخوف الناس
او انه كيف هم فعلا خافوا يعني ممكن تاخذه
من الجانب الشرير التفسير الشرير او
تاخذها من التفسير الجيد التفسير الجيد مع
المتحولين ويقول لك يا اخي الحمام الحريم
اه هنا لا وقف ما حاله وانا في حالي مالي
شغل فيه هذا صار يمسني مباشره
هذه جزئيه الجزئيه الثانيه بداوا يتخوفون
من موضوع
انه طيب الحين طلعت علاجات في اساليب
علاجيه
انتبه ترى بكره بيقنعون ولدك انه متحول
وبيمشون
ما يصير يعني ولو بتروح اصلا ولكن هذه
الافكار تروج اليوم في الاعلام وتروج في
الاعلام اليمني لتخويف الناس يعني انت ما
تقدر تلوم واحد مهما سوى فيها انه يعني
تقدمي وانا احسن واحد في الدنيا وهذا في
النهايه لما تقولوا يا أخوي تدخل الحرمه
في حمام رجال ولا رجال في حمام واقف
ما يعني
يتقبل الشهاده بسهوله يعني عنا اتذكر كيف
يوسف
مره ممتاز كل جوانبه ممتازه وتاييدها كاسح
بس في جزئيه الحمامات هذه
وسقطه
يا حبيبي
فهذه عشان كذا التركيز المشكله مهيب مع
المتحولين كاشخاص بقدر ما هي مع انه
الموضوع صار يمس غير المتحولين لما تيجي
تتكلم على منافسات الرياضيه خاصه على
مستوى المنادل على مستوى المدارس على
مستوى الجامعات على مستوى الاتحاد
الرياضية يقول لك يا اخي يجيني رجوع
العظام وعضلات وهذا يروح يدخل مع الحريم
كذا ظلمهم انا كده يعني
اذا كنت انا حرام عنها يا اخي انا ينافسني
الرجال ياخذ الفرصه لانه عنده اختلاف جيني
عني لانه مختلف عني مو لانه احسن مني انا
نفس حريم وارجع لنفسه رجال تجيب لي رجال
ينافسني
فانا لا وقف المهم بحقك هذا متعيش على كيف
كيف بيتكم بس ما تجي على حسابي ما تيجي
تدخل حمامي ولا تيجي تنافسني في رياضتي
فهذه عشان كذا صارت الحمله ناجحه لانها
فعلا مست مخاوف اساسيه عند قطاع واسع من
الشعب بعض الشعب يقول لك لا انا اعرف انه
هذا الكلام هذا مجرد تخويف وهذا كلام فاضي
ومبالغات وغير صحيح وبعض الشعب لا مقتنع
انه لا فعلا يعني اوكي انا انا الناس
هذولي انا بصوت
وكله دخل في الشيخ الحرب الثقافيه طيب
نقدر نقول انه امريكا يعني دوله تقدميه
وعندها هذه الفكره في
لكنها ما استطاعت الى الان انها ترشح
رئيسه
امراه حتى الان وما استطاعت انها ترشح غير
ابيض الا اوباما يعني
فواضح انه في عندهم هذا يعني انه يمثلهم
الرجل الابيض فقط
ليش رغم ان ربما مثلا حكموا يمكن 16 امراه
يعني على المئه سنه الماضيه في دول عربيه
واسلاميه يعني
هذا الذي ذكرناه امريكا دوله تقليديه اكثر
بكثير من باقي من العالم الغربي اكثر
تقليديه واكثر محافظه من الغرب يعني
بالمقاييس الغرب جدا تقليديه وجده محافظه
ما تحب تغيير كثير تغيير عندها بطيء كثير
من باقي دول الغرب من عرض التغيير اللي هو
على مستوى الرؤساء يعني عنده انا ما اتكلم
بس على رؤسابيه نتكلم على الرجل ابيض
بروتستانتي يعني في تاريخ امريكا حكمها
اثنين كاثوليك واحد منهم بايدن وبايدن جاي
يعني بظروف خاصه جدا والثاني
واحد اسود اللي هو اوباما
كلهم رجل ابيض
عندهم النظره التقليديه عندهم النظره
المحافظه ما يحبون تغيير بقدر غيرهم وحتى
في موضوع يعني موضوع الحريم بالذات موضوع
النساء عندهم تحفظ اكثر من غيرهم يعني انا
اتذكر قبل لا يصير ربما رئيس قبل لا يترشح
اصلا كانوا يسالوني يقولون متى بتصير
عندنا رئيس امراه
فاذكر واحد
بيجي رئيس اسود
بعدين بيجي رئيس لاتينو بعدين بيجي رئيس
اسيوي بعدين بتيجي
فعندهم فعلا يعني ما هو ما هو شيء ظاهر
ولكنه موجود في داخليتهم رفض التغيير
بدرجه يعني اعلى من غيرهم طيب بما اننا
نتكلم عن الانتخابات اليوم
بدات يعني رحله الانتخابات الامريكيه اللي
الانتخابات 24 كيف تقرا المشهد طبعا حنا
يعني ما زال مملا فتره طويله
ويعني
عمر يظهر في مسجدات كثير ويختفي اشياء
كثير
قابل لكثير من التغيير فما تقدر تقول اللي
بيصير
سنه ونص عمر في عمر سنه في عمر الانتخابات
يتغير فيها كل شيء كل شيء تماما ممكن تغير
خلال سنه فما بالك بسنه ونص لو لم يتغير
اي شيء لو الانتخابات بكره
ترامب هو مرشح لاسم الجمهوريس هذا لو ما
تغير شيء بيكون هذا الوضع بايدن هو الرئيس
نعم ما راح يعني
لن يخسر الانتخابات اذا كان المرشحه اذا
كان
غالبا لما نقول عاليه الناس يفهمون يعني
زي لما كانت في انتخابات 2016 لما كانت
بين ترامبو كانوا يقولون يعني احتمال فوز
هلالي عالي فقالوا ينفذ ترامب ما عندك
سالفه لا عالي بس ممكن نفوز ترامب حاليا
احتمال ترشح ترامب احتمال الفوز بالترجيح
عالي ولكن غير مؤكد يعني هو اقرب المرشحين
حظ والمشكله الكبرى انه كل يعني اقرب
المنافسين
الانتخابات العامه لانه
من اليمين
قاعد يصير ترامبي اكثر من ترامب فهم
يقولون انه ترامب بدون دراما لا هم يقولون
عندي الاصل
النخب ترامبي اللي مؤيد ترامب عندي
اللي ما هو مخلص جدا لترامب
عنده تحفظات على ترامب موجوده عندي
اما انه يقول انا ما عندي اصلا اي فرصه
للفوز الا لو اخذت قاعده فبالتالي انا
بمشي بالمسار هذا انفزت فزت اما فزت انا
قاعد اسس لنفسي قاعده لدوره قادمه
انه يامل بانه بيختفي من الصوره بشكل او
باخر يعني ممكن
اي مصيبات
[موسيقى]
فيصير قاعدته خلاص بلكي انا انا ما حد
يقدر ينافسني عليها
المرشدين الثانيين كلهم قاعدين يحاولون
يتخذون مصاري اوكي انا قريبه من ترامبو
وهذا
ما في اسم قوي يعني يمكن الاسم الوحيد
اللي قد يكون امامه فرصه لاننا ما نعرفه
يعني اذا عرفناهم ممكن
نرى انه فعلا وممكن نرى انه لا ولكن
اليهود تمسكت اسكت هو الوحيد اللي بعيد عن
ترامب بما يكفي لاستذاب الجمهوريين
الرافدين لانه الجمهوريين الجمهوريين
ثلاثه في الفئه الاولى اللي هم هذول ترامب
ولا يعني
الفئه الثانيه فئه ليست بالضروره ضد ترامب
يعني ممكن تكون الى حد ما مؤيده لترامب او
مؤيد بشكل كبير او بشكل محدود ولكن ترى
انه يجب التغيير
الترامب مرحله وانتهت لابد من قياده جديده
بتوجهات جديده تحيا الحزب من جديد يعني
نحو الامان
الفئه الثالثه اعدائها معادين ترامب هذول
بعضهم ما زال موجود داخل الحزب وبعضهم
طلعوا اغلبيه
يشوف اللي نسبتهم واضحه قاعده ترامب حول
30% من جمهوريه
الفئتين الثاني مو واضحه التقسيم خصوص
ا اللي ما زال منهم باقي داخل الحزب
يخفيها
ما هو بالضروره يظهر للعلن يعني ما هو كل
الناس رمني يطلع وهاجمه ترامب وهذا لانه
عنده قاعده قويه يقدر يدري انه ما حد يقدر
ينافسه فبالتالي يقدر يقولها في كثير
يعملون عليها مو بس يعني يرونها يعملون
عليها ولكن
الجدد مثلا
همم يعني دائمه في جدد دائما في ناس
ينتقلون بين الاحزاب يعني في كل دوره
انتخابيه فيما لا يقل عن اثنين في المئه
من ناخبين كل حزب يصوتون الحزب الثاني
يعني التبادل واحيانا يكون مجرد تسجيل
قديم واحيانا يكون لا انه فعلا تغير
فدائما في تغير اضافه لانه انت اصلا تلعب
على الهوامش يعني عنا عندنا حوالي تقريبا
من 80 الى 90% من الناخبين هذا صوتهم
محسوم مسبقا
الى 20% الباقيين هذولي هم سلوك سياسي
يعني صوت غالبا معين ولكنه دائما احيانا
يعني ممكن 70% 80% من المرات يصوت مع
الجمهوريين والباقي مع الديمقرايين او
العكس هذول هم اللي يحسبون الانتخابات
الفئه هذه بس والباقيين منها
ومحاوله اقناعهم يعني هم فقط هذول ما يتم
المخاطباتهم الا في الانتخابات الاوليه
لانه لما يكون الحزب قاعد يصفي داخله بيني
وبين بعض يخاطب الناس هذولي لانه هذول هم
يختارون مرشح الحزب ولكن المشكله مشكله
الانتخابات الاولية بالمشاركه فيها متدنيه
يعني نتكلم عن انتخابات 2016
لانه في 2016 هي اخر مره كان في اثنين
مرشحين جدا ما كان في رئيس سعاده ترشيحه
مجموع اللي صوته في الانتخابات الاوليه
لكل الحزبين
56 مليون
اللي صوته في الانتخابات العامه حول 136
مليون يعني في عندنا ملقة تسعين مليون ما
صوته في الانتخابات الاوليه بينما صوت
الانتخابات العامه وهذول الكثير منهم مخلص
لحزبه ومع ذلك ما راح يختار المرشح فلما
تيجي ندخل المرشحين الحزب انا في الفتره
هذه اركز على مين اللي بيروح يصوت عشان
اخذ ترشيحه بعدين اروح افكر في حق
الانتخابات العامه وفي النهايه كلها هوامش
كلها تتكلم على نسب بسيطه
فعلا لانه دائما
الانتخابات يفوز فيها سبعين في المئه ولا
80% هذا دائما
يعتقل او انه يدانه وغيره هي
الاشياء اللي ممكن تبعدي عن يعني
يعني حتى لو ادين ترى قانون
[موسيقى]
ما في اي شيء على موضوع الادانه
قوانين الولايات
وحتى على الاداره الفيدراليه فيه يعني فيه
فقره تتكلم عن العمل ضد الدوله
فيعني لو ادين بعمل ضد الدوله بس هل
الجريمه يعني
كل التهم اللي وجهت له سابقا ما فيها اي
شيء يدينه بالشيء هذا بحيث انه يمنع ترشحه
الاخيره هذه اللي اعلنوها
هي 37 انا قريت منها 29 ما فيها بس ما
اتوقع انه حتى الباقي ما توقعنا فيه لانه
في موضوع تامر قالوا انه في تامر بس
النص التهمه يبدو لي انه التامر ضد
التحقيقات مو ضد الدوله
فبالتالي بس اذا كان دخل تحت قانون التجسس
قد يعني قد يطلع فيها من يحاول انه
يؤكد التفسير هذا عن طريق حكم محكمه انه
يروح للمحكمه يقول ترامب ما يحق له يترشح
لانه
تنظر في الموضوع ويدخل في تفاصيل ولكنه
مبدئيا لا حتى لو سجن ممكن يدخل
الانتخابات لا الدستور ما يقول
مشكله طيب الحين عندنا الحزب الجمهوري
الحزب الديمقراطي بيكون بايدن
يعني ما لم يجي له مثلا جلطه ولا شيء
ومعك كل اللي جاي يصير يعني
في كثير يشكك في قدرات العقليه يعني
تصير في تضخيم يعني في عهده
يعني الحكومه تصرف اكثر عنده البطاله عندك
التضخم اعلى
[موسيقى]
اربعين سنه الماضيه فيعني عهده ليس
بالضروره حتى جيد بخلاف من هو بايدن
المشكله عند بعض الناس لما تبدا تطرح له
الكلام هذا
يعني يبدا يفسر انه هذه رؤيتك هذه ما هي
رؤيتي هذه رؤيه الديمقراطيين الديمقراطيين
اليوم في امريكا وش قاعدين يقولون يقول لك
البطاله في انزل مستوى في تاريخ امريكا في
الاقتصاد الامريكي في افضل حالاته في
تاريخ امريكا
التضخم في امريكا اقل من كل دول العالم
الثاني
النمو
الاحتياطي الفيدرالي رفع الفائده بقفزات
خياليه
عشان يخفضوا التضخم ويخفض النمو
مضحيا برفع البطاله ومع ذلك ما ارتفعت
البطاله
معدل الاجور لاول مره في تاريخ امريكا
يكون اعلن التضخم يعني السنه الماضيه طلعت
تضخم 10% ومعدل ارتفاع الاجور 5%
عاده معدل ارتفاع الاجور وتضخم كلهم بحدود
فلما طلع معدل الاجور 5% وهذه اول مره
بعدين طلعت تضخم عشره اليوم
مره ثانيه جابوا ارتفاع الاجور 5% ثانيه
معناته خلال سنتين اللي حكم فيها بايدن
ويقول لك الاجور زادت 10% وتضخم 5%
فبالتالي انت قاعد تحقق نجاح اقتصادي باهر
ويرون الديمقراطيين ايضا يقولون انه ادار
حرب اوكرانيا بتميز ممتاز
لما كان يحتاج يضغط ضغط لما كان يحتاج
يضبط النفس ضبط النفس ويستشهدون مواقف
كثيره يقول لك مثلا يوم الصاروخ اللي ضرب
بولندا قالوا لو كان اي واحد غير هذا
الشايب هذا الخبره
ثلاثه ايام طلعت التقرير الاستخبارات
بالغلط فيقول لك انه كان اداري الحرب
بحكمه رفع مستوى الضغط على روسيا الاقصى
حد ما يسوي حرب نوويه وقاعد يستنزف روسيا
يقولون هم نفسهم ايضا انه
في عهد ترامب وفي عهد اوباما كلهم جو
باغلبيه ثلاثيه بيت ابيض
وكونجستير كونجرس وكل واحد منهم مره
المشروع واحد
كبير مشروع عمره
واحد اوباما
مررت تخليط الضريبي
سبعه
ويعددونها لك فيقول لك
هذا الرجل قاعد ناجح في كل شيء اوكي تسويق
الاعلامي ما هو جيد الرجل عنده مشاكل كثير
كبير في السن ابيض متدين وهي يعني
الديمقراطيين
من فتره ويقول لك هذا تقليدي اكثر مما نحب
ولكنه في النهايه رجل خاض الرئاسه قال انا
اقدر اهزم ترامب وهزم ترامب وقال وفي
انتخابات 22 كانوا التقدميين شابين يقولون
لا ما ينفع نركز على موضوع الاجهاض وعلى
موضوع حمايه الديمقراطيه ونترك الكلام
اللي قاعد يسال عن التضخم
التضخم سبب لنا مشكله كبيره والكلام كله
على التضخم وعن صرف موضوع كورونا انه طال
وذا لازم
كان يقول لا اللي بيحس بالانتخابات
الجزئتين هذول
يعني الجميع كانوا يقولون هذا هذا مو
يعني انا انا كنت اقول انه
نظريه صعب انها تدفع عدد كبير من الناخبين
وانت امامك موجه حمراء جايه تكتسح الاخضر
واليابس فانت لازم تحاول تقاومها في
النهايه كلام صحيح لان الموجه الحمراء
بشكل ناجح جدا عبر كل ازمات فتره من اسوا
فترات التاريخ فبالتالي سهل اننا نلتقي
حوله انه يكمل مده ثانيه خصوصا انه امريكا
تعيشون جدا الحين لانهم يخافون انه لو
فعلا رجع ترامب للرئاسه انه رايحين
الديمقراطيه حق امريكا ستتحول امريكا من
دوله ديموقراطيه الى دوله تصنطيه يعني
التسلطيه ما هو بالضروره انه يعني يكون
فيها مثلا اعتقالات ولا كذا لا بس بيكون
شكله الحكم ما في تداول للسلطه خلاص
حقيقي من الشيء هذا يعني يقول لك هذا خوف
وجودي
طبعا ما هو جميع بس انه في فئه ترى الشيء
هذا فبالتالي يقول لك لا احنا ناس مدام
بايدن مقتنع انه قادر صحيه على الحكم اربع
سنوات ثانيه راح نصوت له
يطلعون مرشح جديد قادر على انه يحكم
امريكا بشكل افضل من بايدن
يقول
الرجل ناجح ناجح جدا وبعدين لو قال انا
برشح نفسي
لهم ثقل من داخل الحزب يعني زي هذا
كندي اللي ترشح كندي جوني هذا يعتبر خارج
الحزن
حتى انه كان مرشح ديموقراطي فالبس لو جاء
احد من داخل وحاول يناقشه تمزيق للحزب وش
يضمن لي انه ما ياثر على الانتخابات
العامه تخيل انه الرئيس لا يعاد ترشيحه
لانه هزمه واحد من حزبه
بتكون بتكون اضعاف كبير للحزب بعدين بتدخل
مرحله لملبه الصفوف ورجع الناس وهذا زي
اللي صار في 2020 لما فاز بايدن على طول
بدا يشتغل على موضوع لملمه الصفوف انا ليش
اصلا ادخل في صراع ادخل بعده بلملمة صفوف
وانا مقبل على انتخابات انا عندي رئيس
قاعد في البيت الابيض احتمال فوزه بدون اي
شيء ما يقل عن ثمانيه
لانه تاريخيا لما تحسن بنسبه فوز الرؤساء
بعاده الانتخاب 85% النسبه
انا اصلا بعدي من 85% وجع راسي ليش ما راح
يصير الشيء هذا الا لو قالوا والله يا ناس
انا استحمل
او وهو ما قال شيء هذا هو قاعد مصر انه لا
انا صحتي تستحمل او لو صار له عرض صحي
يعني
وهذا ممكن ممكن يدخلهم في متاهه وهذا
قبل الانتخابات بفتره قصيره بحيث انه ما
عاد يمديهم يرشحون احد ثاني يصير له شيء
وهارس شعبيتها ضعيف يعني ما هي ضعيفه
ولكنها لا تكفي انها تكون مرشح رئاسي قوي
طيب الحين عندنا بايدن وعندنا
الجمهوريه ممكن يكون غيره انت تقول انه
بغض النظر عن هذا اذا كان هو المرشح بعدين
يعني
ولكنه انا اقول ترامب ما يقدر
ترامب كمرشح رئاسي مرشح ضعيف
لانه في فئات تكرهه كره عالي في فئات تحبه
محبه عاليه ولكن اللي يكرهونه اكثر من
اللي يحبونه في ناس كثير
ما راح يصوت في الانتخابات
لو كانت مرشح بيروح صوت مهما كان الشخص
وفي ناس قد يصوت للمرشح الجمهوري اذا كان
المرشح الجمهوريه
هذه موجوده ولا باس بها ولكنها اثبتت 18
وعشرين و22 ان الفئه هذه غير كافيه الفوز
على مستوى الوطني
في حال فوز بايدن في الاربع سنين
يعني من التنبؤ لانه الكنغس وضعه بيختلف
انت لا تنسى يعني في امل
للديمقراطيين انهم يساعدون اغلبيه ولكنه
ما هو كبير مش الشيوخ اصعب كثير يعني وضع
الديمقراطيين في مجلس الشيوخ ماساوي
الانتخابات الجايه
فالانقسام هذا ممكن البلد يعني ممكن
يدخلني بمرحله شبيهه بالترامب في اخر
سنتين او اوباما في اخر ست سنوات انه يكون
في انقسام ويكون يعني ما فيه قدره على
التمرير مع العلم انه
مكان المجلس الشيوخ اثبت انه
يبي يشتغل في بعض الاشياء يعني مع اوباما
كان معطل كلش مع بايدن لا
هل هو هو تغير هل هو بايدن
بس انه فعلا ترى البلد دخل في مرحله تعطيه
الخطيره فبالتالي كان يعني يحتاج فعلا
التمرين وما كان يمرر ولا شيء يعجبه يعني
ما كان يمر شيء ما يعجبه بس يعني شفنا
الحين مثلا الدين يعني
كل كم سنه يطلعون كان ترسل اخر لحظه ايه
هذه هذه المتطرفين هم اللي يسحبون
لانه لو تلاحظ في 2011 صارت نفس المواجهه
هذه من اللي كان في الواجهه
باسم الجمهوريين وكان بايدن بصفته نائب
رئيس
الشغل بينهم ومروا ماساه كبيره ونفس الشيء
ما خلصوا
متطرف جدا يعني يجي يقول لك انا بخلي
امريكا
تنفذ كل مطالبه بدون تنازل عن اي شيء
تقولوا مطالبك يقول لك نرجع المعدل الصرف
حق عشرين
في كل شيء الا الجيش
والسوشيال سكيورتيكير
اذا سويت الشيء هذا اذا حطيت هذول كل شيء
يعني الاجمالي الميزانيه هو الاجمالي حق
22 وهذه البنود الثلاثه حطيتها لا
بحق 23 او اكثر معناته باقي البنود بتخفض
اكثر من 50%
هذا واحد اثنين احد اكبر انجازات بايدن في
فطرته انه مرر اللي يسمونه قانون مكافحه
التضخم قانون مكافحه التضخم هذا اسمه
غشاش يعني وفعليا هو قانون البنيه التحتيه
حق بايدن اللي كان اسمه
ويغلفونه من جديد
للمستقبل موضوع السيارات الكهربائيه موضوع
الدعم الطاقه الخضراء موضوع كل التغييرات
اللي يخططون انهم يسوونها للمدى الطويل
كلها موجوده في القانون هذا كان لازم كله
يلقى هذا
بالاستثناء كل بنوته يشال تمويل ميزانيه
وينص على انه يوقف تمويله
والا اذا ما صارت الطلبات هذه تفلس الدوله
وهم قاعدين يعني سلوكهم كله يوحي انه
هذولي اشخاص يرى انه هدم المعبد على راس
الجميع ليس بالضروره شيئا يعني قد يكون
جيد يعني في في احتمال انه لا والله ترى
لو نبني من جديد احسن
التعامل مع المتطرفين صعب لما جئت
الاتفاقيه القانون اللي مر اعتقد انه يعني
متعثر شويه يعني ما بعد مره تماما ولكنه
على وشك
ما ترى مسخوط ولا شيء
كل الاشياء هذه ما تنفذت مش اللي حصل اللي
حصل طبعا كانت حلول وسط ما صار
الديمقراطيين كانوا نرفع سقف الدين بدون
ما نغير ولا شيء يعني احنا ممكن نتفاوض
على الميزانيه
عشان المشكله هذه ونتفاوض على الميزانيه
ايضا من الشروط اللي كانوا حاطينها لازم
سقف الدين يرفع الى ما قبل انتخابات 24
يعني لازم ندخل نفس المواجهه مره ثانيه
قبل الانتخابات 24 عشان يبغون يدخلون عشان
يبغون يدخل الانتخابات خسران مواجهه معهم
فاللي حصل انه مده سقف الدين الى 25 الى
يناير 25 بحيث انه ما خلاص ما له دخل
بالانتخابات هذه
الميزانيه تم تخفيضه بس مو يعني لانه
قرروا انه ميزانيه 24 هي نفس ميزانيه 23
ميزانيه 25 يكون زياده فيها 1% بس بعد كذا
مفتوح ما في شروط
ارفعوه الى الى 25
وارفعوا ميزانيه الجيش
بالنسبه معينه
فالديمقراطيين قدموا تنازلات قدموا
تنازلات انه كان عندهم موضوع حق الشرط
العمل
الجمهوريين كانوا يجيبون يفرضون شروط انه
عشان تاخذ في اعانات مخصصه
لادنى طبقات المجتمع حقت متقعي الفقره هذه
اللي يعني بس عشان ما تموت
اللي هي الفوكس
يعني حقت اقل طبقات كانوا يقولون عشان
ياخذها الشخص لازم يكون يعمل
[موسيقى]
الان
نهايه الامبراطوريه وكان يقصد فيها نهايه
امبراطوريه امريكا وهذا الصوت يعني يسمع
مؤخرا بكثره اللي هو الخوف على ان امريكا
لن تكون الدوله العظمى او الدوله الاهم في
العالم
وش اللي يخلي امريك اليوم تعيش هذا الجو
من الخوف على مستقبلهم طبعا جاك دورسي
ولون ماسك وغيرهم من الفئه هذه هذولي ليش
مفكرين
وارائهم فعليا ما لها ثقه يعني الشيء
الوحيد اللي يعطي ارائهم ثقل ونجحهم
العملي نجاحهم العمليه يعني يثبتوا انهم
ناس افداث في مجالات معينه ولكنه لا يعطي
وزن لكلامهم حتى عند الناس يعني المتلقي
العادي يتاثر ولكنه الناس اللي يعني اهل
الحل والرابط والنخب وكذا ما تتنزل
تناظرهم نهائي يعني لانه ما يعتبرهم من
فئه المفكرين ولكن موضوع هاجس نهايه
الامبراطوريه هذا موجود عند الامريكان من
زمان يعني امريكا
كل الامبراطوريات صعدت فهم عارفين انه
الهبوط اتي
فدائما كان عندهم تخوف امريكا ترى في عمر
التاريخ دوله صغيره يعني حتى كامبراطوريه
مسيطره كالقوه الاقوى في العالم ترى كملها
سبعين سنه تقريبا
هذه فتره قصيره في عمر التاريخ معظم
الامبراطوريات سيطرت مده اطول بكثير ومع
ذلك من اليوم الاولهم عندهم العجز هذا من
ايام الحرب البارده وهم عندهم الهاجس
متى بينتهي زمننا
وش بيصير اذا انتهى منه وموجود حتى عند
الناس العاديين
ويتنبؤون فيه باستمرار يعني حتى لما ترجع
لو رحت بحثت عن الكتابات وعن النقاشات
الناس في السبعينات وفي الستينات وفي
الثمانينات وفي التسعينات
ما هو بشكل واسع زي ما نشوفها اليوم
بس فاذا ما هي يعني هي مجرد
سواليف
ما تتجاوز انها
تخوف موجود ولكنه ولكنه قديم ما هو جديد
ما هو شيء طارئ حالي موجود باستمرار وعايش
مع الناس باستمرار والناس متالفين بس يعني
في احصاء يقول انه السبع واربعين في المئه
من الامريكيين يسالون بان امريكا في
انحدار يعني رقم جدا هذا هذا يختلف عن
موضوع الامبراطوريه لانه في انحدر لما
تقولوا في انحدار ترى ممكن يكون يفكر
اشياء ثانيه على العالم يفكر في وضعه في
حياته في البلد
يعني قضيه كوبا هذه كانت حادثه استثنائيه
يعني ثوره الهمس لا كانت فتره ممتده وتيار
شعبي كبير يعني كان مكتسع بشعبيته بين
الشباب يعني بين فئات عمريه معينه كم مره
مكتسعه يعني كل الامريكان اللي اعمارهم
اليوم بالسبعين كلهم
عندك بس الصين اليوم يعني تكون قوه اختلاف
انه يمكن اذا اخذنا في الحرب البارده كانت
بس ما بين طرفين اما امريكا وروسيا اليوم
عندنا الصين روسيا اوروبا
دول كثيره تكبر فلم ما صارت انا واخر انا
والدول مختلفه فتوزع القوى فهذا ممكن يضع
في امريكا برضو شوف يعني عادي معها اليوم
مثلا يمكن مو لازم مرحله نهار بس انا
اتوقع اني بكون يمكن الثاني يمكن الثالث
كقوه عظمى لا فاذا تتكلم عن نظره
الامريكان الثاني ولا الثالث ما يقبلون
الشيء هذا وهذا شيء يتخوف منه حتى بعض
حلفائه
طيب مش بتسوي امريكا لو جالي يوم الامريكا
شافت نفسها انها ما تقدر تصير الاول
ممكن تتهور ممكن تتهور يعني بتتخذ اجراءات
يعني ممكن يعني بصراحه الاول مثلا كان
الصين او غيره انه تدخل في مرحله انك
تستفزه عشان اكسره عسكريا قبل الاسلام
الاول فهم فهم الشيء هذا
تخوفون من الشيء هذا ولكن الحقيقه انه
انت لما تقولي على تقدم الصين او تقدم
الهند او البرازيل او روسيا
انت كانك تقول لي في فريق فايز في مباراه
الذهاب 7-0
فممكن في الاياب يفوز سبعه واحد ولا سبعه
اثنين فقط هذا الفارق لانه
تاريخ الحديث
الصراع بين امريكا والاتحاد السوفيتي كان
في برلين في الجزائر عنده جزاره باللين في
نص اوروبا الغربيه
الصراع بين امريكا وروسيا اليوم وفي شرق
اوكرانيا على حدود روسيا
ففعليا النفود الامريكي تقدم من برلين الى
حدود روسيا
الصراع بين امريكا والصين كانت
داخل الصين تايوان جزء من الصين يعني
امريكا وصلت الى داخل الصين فبالتالي
فعليا امريكا متقدمه يعني امريكا تعيش
اقوى حالاتها حاليا
الصين ستتقدم وروسيا ستستعيد بعض
منها السابق والهند ستبرز والبرازيل ستبرز
والشرق الاوسط سيبرز وهذا كله يعني سياكل
من سيطره ونفوذ امريكا ولكنه مثل ما قلنا
الفرق بين سبعه صفر ولا سبعه اثنين بس
يعني امريكا ما زال يعني ما زال في
المستقبل للمنظور
الصين مو الاقتصادي
الصين يعني عندها مشاكل
متراكمه بسبت انه سريع
اما انها تتفجر المشاكل هذه عليها او
تفرمت ولو تلاحظون يعني في السنوات
الاخيره منخفض بشكل كبير
يعني امريكا وكان عندها بعد الحرب
العالميه لانه كان العالم كله مدمر فكانت
هي الوحيده اللي عندها مصانع صار عندها
ثوره صناعيه ضخمه صار عندنا نمو عالي
بعدين اضطرتوا عشان توقف التلوث عشان تحسن
الوضع العمال عم يطلع عندنا الاتحادات
العماليه طلعت عندها الحقوق يمكن دوله
شموليه وما عليهم احد قد يعني موضوع
الحقوق العماليه
قد تكون تاثيرها اقل ولكن عندها مشاكل في
التلوث عندها مشاكل في العمله عندها مشاكل
في بعض القطاعات الاقتصاديه الكبيره
ستعيق نموها لما نقول تعقنوها ما معناته
انه الصين يعني بدحدر لا ولكنها بدل ما
تنمو سبعه ولا ثمانيه في الميه
فبالتالي بدل ما هو الفارق بينها وبين
امريكا قاعد يتقلص او يعلق
[موسيقى]
الله يعطيك العافيه الله يعافيك شكرا لكم
شكرا لعمر العمران ومازن العتيبي في اعداد
الحلقه وخلف الكاميرات عبد الرحمن عبود
ومدير التصوير وحاب موسى وفي التحرير محمد
نور الشمت والتلوين عبد المجيد العباس
والهندسه الصوتيه محمد
الحسن وفي اداره محتوى التواصل الاجتماعي
السبيعي ومنتج فنجان ايمن الحمادي وفي
دائره التحرير اسيل عبد الله هذا فنجان
احد منتجات شركه الثمانيه للنشر والتوزيع
ننشر كل الانتاج بحب من مدينه الرياض
الاسبوع المقبل
غير انه
الرئيس ما راح يصير رئيس تراب
[موسيقى]
اخر مره اخر مره
فازوا الجمهوريين باغلبيه الاصوات كانت
من بوش الاب الى اليوم ما فازوا
الا مره واحده كانت عقب الحرب عقب احداث
11 سبتمبر فكان
له يعني من اثر الحرب غيرها
كم سبع ثمان دورات الحين
اعلى بس ممكن طيب الموضوع التقسيمات
الغريبه حقتهم هذه ياخذون الجمهوريين
الديمقراطيين على مستوى الكونغرس على
مستوى النواب
على العالم
زي ما بيقولوا
تاريخيه تبحث على اسباب
نظريات السقوطات يعني ما بحثت في المواضيع
هذه بدرجه اني اقدر افتي بس احتمال غريب
والله يعلم مهما
مهما حاولت اني اقول لا عادي كل واحد
اهتمامات حلوه بس اهتمامك وقدرتك في
المعرفه والالمام بالموضوع لا اله الا
الله انا حاب حاب يعني التاريخ من زمان
واقرا فيه من زمان وكان اطلاعي على تاريخ
امريكا مو كبير
ولكنه تعرف حكمه الافلام والمسلسلات
فعندنا اطلاع على الاجتماع ولكن ما عندنا
اطلاع على التاريخ وعلى السياسه بشكل كبير
فلما رحت امريكا تفكر انه انا الحين
ابي اعرف البنات هذا شلون ماشي
يعني
تقاطع وشلون هذه ابغى ابغى اعرف اكبر كميه
من المعلومات عن طريقه اداره البنات قبل
ارجع
عشان نفس الوقت في الجامعه درست تاريخ
امريكا ودراسه النظام السياسي حق امريكا
كم مبادئ اللي تعطل كل الطلبه وحلي
عجبني الموضوع حسيت بمتعه لدرجه اني كنت
اسجل مواد في الجامعه مره تخصصي تماما
الدكاتره الى الحين يعني يعتبروني
هذا حق الكمبيوتر
[ضحك]
لا لا دكاتره ذولا
واربعين سنه
[ضحك]
والله جيتي يعني اكثر من المعتادة
لحالي واذا رجعت بتجي زوجتي
عشان بنتي عندها دراسه
اجازه اكثر من شهر اه صح يقول ما اقدر
اروح المشوار هذا كله في الاخير اسبوعين
ما اقدر ما اقدر
اه بسافر وين رايح والله بروح دبي ما شاء
الله دبي
اقعد في الطياره 16 ساعه عشان اسبوع ليش
انا بروح اليونان هو حلو يا اخي اليونان
جميله كيف تقعد خمس ايام اقل شيء اقل شيء
يوم عن كل ساعه في الطياره هذا الحد
الادنى
يوم على كل ساعه في الطياره هذه ما في اقل
منها ابدا
14 ساعه في الطياره بعدين نروح 5 ايام 14
ساعه
اقل من كده المفروض يسحبون